programming throwdown episode 172 transformers and large language models. Take it away, Jason. Hey, everybody. I had a really interesting discussion on LinkedIn. This is like a meta meta thing, but I post everything on LinkedIn and Twitter and my Twitter, nobody follows my Twitter. And the weird thing is I, my ex, yeah. Maybe it's going to be my ex social network. I just can't get anybody to follow me on there. Everyone follows me on LinkedIn,
Programming Throwdown 第 172 期：Transformer 与大语言模型。Jason，开始吧。大家好。我在 LinkedIn 上进行了一场非常有意思的讨论。这有点像元讨论，但我会在 LinkedIn 和 Twitter 上发布所有内容，而我的 Twitter 没人关注。奇怪的是，我的前社交媒体账号，也许以后会变成我的前社交媒体账号，我就是没法让别人在上面关注我。每个人都在 LinkedIn 上关注我，
which is fine. But I even tried, you know, putting my Twitter link on presentations I give and stuff like that. And, and people would rather just find me on LinkedIn. So I find this amazing that you give presentations where people actually could join and follow you
这没关系。但我甚至尝试过在我的演讲演示中放上我的 Twitter 链接之类的东西。人们还是宁愿在 LinkedIn 上找到我。所以我发现这很神奇，你做的演讲竟然有人真的会去加入并关注你。
i always see people do that but i've never done it myself just not on social social media but i also find it interesting that you have presentations where that would even be an opportunity i gave a amazing presentation to suny purchase which is a university in new york um and it was on the ai singularity and uh um it was it was a lot of fun um had a great time there or i wasn't like i wasn't in person but had a great time speaking oh nice now i kind of want you to give it here i actually would love i asked if if they would make the video public they said no it was actually technically one of the lessons like it was part of a course and so for that reason they can't just post it on the
我总是看到别人这样做，但我自己从没做过，不是因为社交媒体的原因，但我还觉得很有趣的是，你竟然有能提供这种机会的演讲。我在 SUNY Purchase（纽约的一所大学）做了一场很棒的演讲，主题是 AI 奇点，非常有趣，在那儿度过了一段很棒的时光。虽然我不是亲临现场，但演讲过程很愉快。哦，不错，现在我倒想让你在这儿也讲一次。我其实很想，我问过他们是否能公开视频，他们说不行，这实际上是课程的一部分，所以出于这个原因，他们不能直接把它发布在
internet but i was really happy with it the questions were extremely interesting the students were very engaging and um um yeah it's a shame that we can't just share it with everybody but the thing that really kind of took off on linked sometime over the weekend, was I posed this question, is work from home really work from city? And what I meant by that is how many people during the pandemic really moved to a different city and they're not really interested in working from home. That's not the spirit of what transpired it's actually that
互联网上。但我对那次演讲非常满意，学生们提出的问题极其有趣，互动性也很强。唉，没能和大家分享确实很遗憾。不过，周末在 LinkedIn 上真正火起来的是我提出的这个问题：居家办公真的是“从城市办公”吗？我的意思是，在疫情期间，有多少人真的搬到了不同的城市，而他们其实并不想居家办公？这并不是当时情况的初衷，实际上是
they want to work from another place and uh so maybe i'll pose a question to you patrick so if you're if your office was there in your city would you go to it why and why not oh this is interesting uh i think i i see your point and i have seen the statistics although i'm not sure how trustworthy they are i i don't know the questioning to be honest but that not everyone to your point is actually happy about work from home personally um you know relocating to a different city for for a plethora of reasons to your point it's not necessarily that it was only the office it was also the geographic location as much as we are moving to online people you know having family and you know just a laundry list of different
他们想在另一个地方工作。所以，也许我该问问你，Patrick：如果你的办公室就在你所在的城市，你会去吗？为什么会或不会？哦，这很有趣。我想我明白你的意思了，我也看过相关统计数据，尽管我不确定它们有多可信。老实说，我不知道调查的具体内容，但正如你所说，并不是每个人都对居家办公感到满意。就我个人而言，出于多种原因搬到不同的城市，正如你所说，这不一定仅仅是因为办公室，地理位置也同样重要。尽管我们正在转向线上，但人们有家庭，还有一长串不同的
personal reasons for myself but for others as well there can be specific cities you want to live in or don't that being said i the question so it's hard because the place i chose to live is different than where i would potentially have lived if i had tried to locate next to an office that is where an office most likely would be near me would be far and therefore i would not want to go to it oh i see but if there had been an office and i was living close to it it's not that i mind going into an office occasionally. I will turn the flip around, which I'll say by not commuting personally have found ways of, I don't want to say exploiting, that sounds negative. I have found ways of parlaying that time that I would normally have spent in the car into other industrious activities. So things like,
个人原因。对我自己来说，对其他人也一样，可能就是有特定的城市你想住或者不想住。话虽如此，这个问题很难回答，因为我选择居住的地方，和我如果为了靠近办公室而选择居住的地方可能不同。如果办公室离我很远，我肯定不想去。哦，我明白了。但如果附近有办公室，我住得近的话，我不介意偶尔去办公室。我换个角度说，通过不通勤，我个人找到了利用这段时间的方法。我不想说“剥削”，这听起来很负面。我找到了将通常花在车上的时间转化为其他富有成效活动的方法。比如，
you know, being more active and exercising and going out or meeting with people sort of early in the morning because I'm on the East Coast and work with people on the West Coast. And so going and meeting with people I otherwise wouldn't have because I'm working late, basically meeting them in the morning. So replacing commute time by having a time shifted schedule and finding these other things for me means work from home is really about work from home. But I do see your point there is a gradient between office for your full work week hybrid work from city like down the down the list i think there's sort of like a a spectrum and i think it's it's not a it's not a binary choice yeah that
变得更活跃、锻炼身体、出去走走，或者在清晨与人会面，因为我在东海岸，而与西海岸的人共事。所以，我会去见那些我本来见不到的人，因为我工作到很晚，基本上是在早上见他们。所以，通过错峰工作来替代通勤时间，并找到这些其他事情，对我来说，居家办公确实就是居家办公。但我明白你的观点，在全职办公室工作和居家办公之间存在一个梯度，就像“从城市办公”一样，我认为这更像是一个光谱，而不是一个二元选择。是的，这
makes sense you know one of the reasons, so I was working in Austin. So like when I moved to Austin, I did work in an office here. And then recently I switched to working from home, which wasn't a choice. It was part of just things that transpired at my company. And so now all the Austin folks are remote. There's definitely pros and cons. I'm a bit ambivalent to it but what i really want to do is sort of blunt this argument that um i feel like when they create this dialectic of you have
说得通。你知道其中一个原因，我曾在奥斯汀工作。当我搬到奥斯汀时，我确实在那里的办公室工作过。后来我转为居家办公，这不是我的选择，而是公司内部变动的结果。所以现在奥斯汀的所有员工都是远程办公。这肯定有利有弊。我对此有点矛盾，但我真正想做的是反驳这样一个论点：我觉得当他们制造这种“办公室人员”与“居家人员”的辩证法时，很容易让像埃隆·马斯克这样的人说，哦，居家办公的人很懒，他们整天只想坐着吃多力多滋之类的。所以我觉得那个论点的整个前提是错误的，因为我想知道大多数人是否真的……他们居家办公不是为了居家办公，而是为了住在别的地方。所以，那种“这个人不想起床”的刻板印象，在前提上根本就不成立。我想是的，我觉得这是一种没有普世真理的情况。我的意思是，我可以想象一个理论上的人，就是那种经典的
you have people in the office and people at home then it's easy for like i think elon musk is one of these people who says oh people working from home are lazy you know they just want to sit eat doritos all day whatever um and so i feel like you know the entire premise of that argument is false in the sense like like i would i wonder if the majority of people actually you know they're not working from home to work from home they're working from home to live somewhere else and so then you know the whole uh this whole stereotype of like oh this person doesn't want to get out of bed is really not not even true on the premise i think yeah i i feel like it's one of those cases where it's there's no universal truth i mean i could imagine a you know theoretical person that you know this is the classic goes
整天泡在茶水间的人，对吧？实际上干扰了其他试图工作的员工，基本上找到了不坐在工位上工作的方法，因为他们不忙，还试图掩盖这一点。在我的职业生涯中，我一直认识这样的人。对于那个人来说，如果他们这样做是为了避免看起来不忙，那么居家办公对他们来说就是一个“启示”，因为他们可以随心所欲，没人知道他们是否在工作。然后你就会看到公司推出的那些鼠标追踪软件之类的东西来应对这种情况。所以我确实认为有这样的人，但是
and spends all their time at the water cooler right and actually causes a distraction of other other employees trying to work and you know basically finds ways of not being at their desk and not working because they're not busy and they're trying to cover for it throughout my career i've always known people that that have you know been more or less like that and that for that person going home if they're doing that specifically to avoid the appearance of you're not being busy then going from his is a is a you know a revelation to them because they could just do whatever they want and no one knows if they're working or not and then you get all the like you know mouse tracking software that you see companies roll out or whatever to combat this so i do think there are people like that but
就像你说的，我不知道这是否是普遍真理，不能因为你居家办公就意味着你在吃奇多，而且没穿裤子。是的。好吧，我们看看结果如何。但这确实引发了热烈的讨论。如果你想在 LinkedIn 上关注我，那里的人们确实会回应我那些愚蠢的问题，
like you said i i don't know that that's universally true that just because you work from home means you're like eating cheetos and don't have any pants on. Yeah. All right. Well, we'll see where that goes. But there's a lively discussion. If you want to follow me on LinkedIn, where people actually respond to my inane questions,
你可以在 LinkedIn 上关注我，看看一场非常有趣的讨论正在展开。有一件事，我知道这会发生，所以我试图避免它，但你无法完全避免。你知道，我知道这会发生，所以我试图避免它，但你无法完全避免。有些人把它当作是对湾区的攻击，但这并不是重点。我试图强调，如果科技公司不在那里，会有同样多的人向相反的方向奔跑。如果你反过来想，如果科技公司不在那里，会有同样多的人向相反的方向奔跑。
you can follow me on LinkedIn and see a really interesting discussion unfolding. One thing is, you know, and I knew this would happen, so I tried to avoid it, but you can't completely avoid it. You know, you know, and I try, I knew this would happen. So I tried to avoid it, but you can't completely avoid it. You know, some people took it as a, like, attack on, you know, the Bay Area. And that wasn't really the point. You know, and I tried to make a point of saying, look, there's just as many people who would be running the other direction. If the tech companies weren't already there, you know, like, if you were to flip the script, there'd be just as many people who would be running the other direction if the tech companies weren't already
你知道，如果你反过来想，湾区会有同样多的人在居家办公，而他们的总部在佛罗里达，他们会说，哦，这不都一样吗？所以这与哪个地方更好无关，只是关于人们为什么要离开。对于一个稍微不同的问题，我的意思是，如果一家公司想把“从城市办公”作为一种灵活性提供，你觉得这可行吗？WeWork 现在好像快破产了，我上次看到是这样。但你对这最终会变成什么样有什么看法？是的，我喜欢它。我们有一个 WeWork。简短的故事是，我曾是一家初创公司的一员，
there you know like if you were to flip the script there'd be just as many people in the bay area working from home while their hq is in florida saying like oh you know it'd be the same thing right so it's not it's not about which place is better or any of that it's just about why are people um leaving and for for a subtly different question i mean do you have a like if a company wanted to offer work from city as a flexibility like is that something you imagine i mean we work is now i think going towards bankruptcy i think is last i saw but i mean i i mean what what is your like do you have a thought towards like what that ends up looking like yeah i mean i i loved it so we had a we work um basically the the short story here is i was part of a startup
如你所知，初创公司的规则相对较少。当然，它仍然是一家公司，但它是一家小公司，所以我们有 WeWork。初创公司被一家大得多的公司收购了，大公司对什么是办公室有一堆规定。而 WeWork 无法满足这些规定，所以所有的 WeWork 都被关闭了。基本上就是这样。但我很喜欢它。我会进去，那里会有来自各种不同行业和不同微型办公室的人。这很有趣。那里有很好的公共区域，你可以见到人。所以我是一个大粉丝。我其实会骑自行车去市中心，单程大约 12 英里，那是我一整天的锻炼。所以我骑车去市中心，工作，然后骑车回来。是的，那是我喜欢的生活方式。但居家办公，我觉得也挺好的。是的，也许我对此相当
as you know a startup has relatively few rules i mean obviously it's still a corporation and everything but it's a small company and so we had a we work uh startup was acquired by a much bigger company and the bigger company has a bunch of rules around what constitutes an office. And WeWork wasn't able to fit those rules. And so all the WeWorks got shut down. Basically, it's what happened. But I loved it. I would go in, there would be a bunch of people
矛盾，这看起来没什么不同。我想，我团队里的很多人本来就不在我的城市。所以我无论如何都要花很多时间在网上和他们交流。好吧，去 LinkedIn 上看看吧，讨论还在继续。但你得注册一个账号，Patrick。我想我某个地方有一个，我得把它找出来。现在是节目新闻时间。
from all sorts of different industries and different micro offices. That was interesting. There's nice common areas where you can meet people um so i was a big fan i actually um i would ride my bicycle to downtown which is something like 12 miles each way um and that would be my whole exercise for the day so i bike in a downtown i would uh you know work um bike, bike back. And yeah, it was a lifestyle that I was enjoying. But working from home, I think has been pretty much fine. Yeah, maybe I'm pretty
为了配合“不是新闻故事”的故事，我们真的应该重命名这些部分。这是一篇标题为《初级开发人员对成为高级开发人员的错误认知》的文章。那个人的名字，至少我假设他叫 Vadim。我不确定怎么读。听起来是对的。好吧，如果他在听，我表示歉意。他们在这里提出了一些很棒的观点，这是一篇发人深省的文章，也就是，
ambivalent to this, you know, it doesn't seem all that different. I think, you know, a lot of the people in my team were not in my city anyways. So I was spending a lot of time, you know, on the internet with them anyways. Well, check it out on LinkedIn. The discussion continues there. But you have to make an account, Patrick. I think I have one somewhere. I'll have to dig it out. Time for news of the show.
我的职业生涯稍微长一点。我有时会忘记当你刚入行、对很多事情都不了解时是什么样子。首先，我个人认为在某些公司，初级开发人员和高级开发人员的划分被过度强调了。在某些公司，界限非常明确，而在其他公司则不然。我认为有些人确实具有所谓的“初级”和“高级”特征。所以也许我的心态已经回答了其中一些问题，但这些观点很值得指出。我不知道，我是否都认同。但一个例子是，高级开发人员就一定知道所有答案。我认为这显然是不对的。高级开发人员，或者至少我没见过哪个高级开发人员
So fitting with not being a news story story we should just really rename these sections uh this one was a article that uh was titled falsehoods junior developers believe about becoming senior and uh just uh the the person's name at least i assume his name is Vadim. I'm not sure how to say it. Sounds right. Okay. Apologize if you're listening. And they had some great points here that is just a thought-provoking article, which is,
真的知道所有答案。我见过几个自以为知道所有答案的人，但他们实际上并不知道。同样，有一种信念，我们时不时会遇到，就是“哦，你是高级开发人员，你一定在做最前沿的东西，使用当下最流行的语言或结构”。我用 C++，所以“哦，你一定用了所有那些奇奇怪怪的 C++ 特性”。实际上，不，我可能使用的是该语言中最基础的子集，因为对我来说，与队友协作并获得帮助很重要。所以那个人只是指出，并不存在那种“有一天你突然从做初级任务、跑腿买咖啡，转变为写文档和代码，然后有一天你只做酷炫的事情，把所有琐碎的事情都推给别人”的信念。可能确实有虐待狂或有问题的资深开发人员会这样做，但在实践中，这并不属实。随着职位的提升，这确实是一个梯度，你可能会解决更大的问题，但根据我的经验，更大的问题在很大程度上只是较小问题的集合，只有极少数情况下会遇到单一的硬骨头。所以这篇文章很有趣，我没有读完所有内容，我想这里有 10 条左右，但去看看吧，我们会在节目笔记中提供链接。你有什么想法？这很棒。是的。
you know, I have been in my career a little bit longer. I can sometimes forget what it was like when you're sort of new and you don't understand a lot of stuff um first of all i mean i personally think the junior developer senior developer thing is is overdone at some companies it's a very strong delineation at other companies it's not uh i i think there are people who are have characteristics of being quote unquote junior and senior um and so maybe my mindset already sort of like answer some of these, but these are great to point out. I don't know, I hit on all of them. But an example of is that a senior developer just knows all the answers. And I think that's obviously not true. Like senior developers, or at least I've not met a senior developer who
我想，我实际上见过事情向相反方向恶化的情况。当某人成为技术主管时，他们会说：“好吧，我团队的福利现在非常重要。因此，我要做那些没人愿意做的、糟糕的工作。”这样我的团队就会很开心。然后一年后，他们完全精疲力竭，讨厌自己的生活和一切。你开始深入了解，发现哦，是的，他们已经做了一年的最差工作。这根本不可持续。所以我认为它实际上
actually knows all the answers. I've met a few who thought they knew all the answers, but they don't actually know all the answers. Similarly, there's a belief, and we bump into this from time to time that, oh, you're a senior developer, like you must work like the cutting edge stuff and, you know, insert whatever language is, you know, hip at the moment or constructs in the language you're working in. So I work c++ like oh you must use all the insert exotic c++ stuff and it's actually like no i use probably one of the more basic subsets of the language because it's important for me to get collaboration and get help from teammates and so the person just pointing out that you know there's not this belief that you somehow fundamentally shift that one day you're doing sort of junior tasks and fetching coffee that's not this belief that you somehow fundamentally shift that one day you're doing sort of junior tasks and fetching coffee, that's not the equivalent of as writing documentation
更多时候是向相反的方向发展。是的，我想也许收获是，随着级别的提升，你变得越来越像更多人的仆人。所以，是的，它不是那样发展的。但我作为初级开发人员时也有同样的感觉。所以这很有趣，如何纠正这种记录呢？它不在那里。我想，正如你所说，如果你是虐待狂，你现在有权力和影响力去成为一个虐待狂。但如果你是虐待狂，
and then code. And then one day you're not you're doing only cool stuff. And you're just pawning off all the mundane things and whatever. There may be sadistic or problematic, you know, senior developers who do that, but that's in practice, not really true. And it really is a gradient as you move up, you may be solving bigger bigger problems but bigger problems are really just large collections of smaller problems in my experience for the most part with very rare occasional you know singular tough nuts to crack and so interesting article i i didn't read them all i think there's you know like 10 here um but check it out we'll have a link in the show notes. Uh, what are your thoughts? This is, this is great. Yeah.
你可能很难获得晋升。这并非不可能，但更难。所以它会自我调节。是的，我的意思是，文化和管理是后盾，这取决于你的团队是如何运作的，这决定了如果你是在一家非工程、非软件工程公司中为数不多的软件开发人员之一，情况会与你在一家大型科技公司有所不同。我认为这些情况的发展和演变方式可能非常不同。是的。好吧。我的新闻故事是“纯追踪”（Pure Pursuit）。
I think, um, I actually have seen things degenerate the other direction where, you know, as someone becomes a tech lead, they say, well, you know, my team's welfare is now really important. Therefore I'm going to do the really, you know, crappy for lack of a better word I'm going to do the really crappy work that no one else wants to do. That way my team is happy. And then a year later, they're completely burnt out and they hate their life and everything. And you kind of start diving into it and you find out, oh yeah, they've been doing the worst work for a year. And that's just not sustainable. So I think it actually you know goes in the
这真的很酷。这是一种设计机器人车辆轨迹优化器的相对简单的方法。例如，想象一下，这是一个例子。以赛车电子游戏为例，对大多数人来说，赛车游戏有点难，因为他们不知道如何构建对手 AI。当你观看马里奥赛车之类的游戏时，这看起来很难。我该如何编写这样的代码？如果他们被玩家撞出赛道，他们该如何回到赛道上？我想，关键是他们与
other direction more often than not um and yeah i guess maybe the thing takeaway is like as you go up in level you become like more and more of a servant to more and more people and and so uh um and so yeah it doesn't it doesn't go that, that way, but, but yeah, I also felt the same way as a junior developer. So this is interesting that like, how do you correct the record there? It's not, it's not there. I guess, you know, with, I guess, you know, if, if, as you said, if you're sadistic, you have now the power and the influence to be a sadist, but if you're sadistic, you know, as you said, if you're sadistic, you have now the power and the influence to be a sadist.
马里奥或敌人不同，他们基本上有自己的物理规则和宇宙。在这种情况下，每个人都是一辆车，如果你不能真正打破规则，如果 AI 在赛道中间传送，这会完全破坏沉浸感。你可以让 AI 跑得更快或更慢，会有“橡皮筋效应”，但它仍然必须遵循与玩家相同的物理约束。否则，游戏就毁了。事实证明，有一整套相对简单的方法可以进行基本的机器人导航和轨迹规划。这就是其中之一，叫做“纯追踪”。
But if you're sadistic, you probably have a really hard time getting promoted. It's not impossible, but it's harder. So it kind of works itself out. Yeah, I mean, culture and management is, you know, I guess the fallback here, which is depending on how your team is run determines how how much if if you're one of a very small number of software developers at a non-engineering non-software engineering company i think it's a little different than if you're uh you know at a at a sort of big tech company i think the how those situations develop and evolve can be very different. Yep. Yep. All right. My news story is Pure Pursuit.
所以我附上了两个链接。一个是相当长的教程，里面有一堆 Python 代码，你可以跟着做，看看他们在做什么。另一个是 YouTube 视频，正如你所想，视觉效果更强。是的，如果你正在寻找一种有趣的事情做，我认为编写这样的代码并让一堆小机器人互相比赛，可以作为添加到 GitHub 账号的一个有趣项目。我想我看到有一个……我猜那是强化学习的人写了一个教程，
This is really cool. It's a relatively simple way of designing a robot vehicle trajectory optimizer. So, for example, imagine like this is an example. Take racing video games right for most people a racing video game is kind of a non-starter because they have no idea how to build the opponent ai and it seems like when you watch um you know even mario kart or something when you watch something when you watch these racing games it can seem really hard like how do i code something like that up and what if they get totally you know bumped by the player way off track how do they get back on track and yeah i guess the thing is like they as opposed to
或者不是教程，是那种你主要为了娱乐而看的关于《赛道狂飙》（Trackmania）的有趣视频，那是一款赛车游戏，虽然不是超级精确，但稍微多一点。所以他们展示了如何通过几代人的努力，去进化或训练一个机器学习代理来获得最佳时间。他们谈论了一些微妙之处，比如你被允许做什么动作或输入，以及是否允许漂移，或者是否试图避免漂移。这是一个非常复杂的话题。我同意 Jason 的观点，我认为这很有趣，而且它有很多……我不想说完全的现实世界应用，但思考这些事情对你在其他领域也有帮助，这些领域是相邻的。所以从制造一架小飞机或四轴飞行器，都会有这些相同的控制回路和
like mario or the enemies basically have their own physics and their own you know universe in this case you know everyone's a car with the same you know if you can't really bend the rules if if if the ai um you know just teleports in the middle of the track or something it completely destroys the immersion you can make the ai go faster and slower and there's rubber banding and some of that but but still like it has to kind of follow the same kind of physics constraints as the player. Otherwise, it ruins the game. And so it turns out there's a whole bunch of relatively simple methods for doing kind of basic robot navigation and trajectory planning. And this is one of them called Pure Pursuit.
阻尼，确保你不会进入振荡状态等等。所以，有没有一个……我不想称之为游乐场，或者设置得很好的地方，你只需要编写驾驶代码就行了？肯定有，我一时想不起来。是的，有一个……让我想想，我能找到它……哦，我忘了它叫什么了……让我看看……是的，有 Carla，哦，Torcs，我想到的是 Torcs。它代表“开放赛车模拟器”（The Open Racing Car Simulator）。Torcs 是为 AI 设计的，你可以玩它，但它主要是为了让 AI 玩。不错。所以我想说，如果你想深入研究
So I included two links. One is a pretty lengthy tutorial that has a bunch of python code where you can um follow along and see what they're doing um the other one is a youtube video where it's as you'd imagine much more visual um and yeah it's a lot of fun if if you're looking for kind of a neat thing to do, I think coding something like this up and having a bunch of little robots race each other could be kind of a fun thing to add to your GitHub account. I think I saw there was a... I guess that's reinforcement learning person wrote a tutorial
那个特定的问题，它可能比从零开始编写马里奥赛车让你更快上手。哦，是的，完全同意。我的意思是，从零开始编写马里奥赛车，你只会做一个非常假的物理引擎，非常傻。但如果你最终想控制一辆真正的汽车，如果你想循序渐进，那么 Torcs 或 Carla 会是一个很好的起点。我的下一个新闻文章，无意中，我想，是你可以用来达到目的的一部分。那就是所谓的“控制回路”或“控制器”，弄清楚给定对现实世界的一些观察，影响一些输出。你可以根据需要让这些词变得华丽或不华丽。我相当不华丽。
or like not a tutorial, one of those funny videos videos I guess you watch mostly for entertainment about track mania which is some you know race car game that is not super hyper accurate but it's you know a little bit more and so they were kind of showing how over generations trying to I guess you call it evolve or train a an ML agent to kind of get the best times. And, you know, they were talking about some of the subtleties about, you know, what moves or inputs you are allowed to do and, you know, whether it was allowed to drift or whether it tried to avoid drifting as an example. It's a very complex topic. And I agree with Jason. I mean, I think it's pretty interesting and it has a lot of, I don't know, I don't want to say like complete real world application, but there's a of uh thinking through these kinds of things that help you in other domains that would be you know sort of adjacent so anything from like building a little you know flying airplane or a quadcopter is gonna have some of these same control loops and
那就是我称之为 PID 控制器。我这里的文章是《没有博士学位的 PID》。Jason 在预演时告诉我们，他说“pid”，我也听过这个说法。所以我们得问问 AI 哪个是正确的。但《没有博士学位的 PID》是一个小 PDF，我得说，它不是最基础的解释，但没有深入到我的背景知识，使得如果你只是看 PID 控制器的维基百科页面，你很快就会被淹没。好吧，那语法不太好。哦，好吧，你会陷入超出你能力的数学中，或者至少是我不习惯的数学，
dampening and you know making sure you don't get into oscillations and these kinds of kind of things as well so yeah i don't is there a like i don't want to call it like a playground or like a something where it's like pretty well set up where where all you have to do is really code in the the kind of like driving there must be no one off the top of my head yeah there was a um let's see i can find it opens oh i forgot what it was called um let me see if i can yeah there's there's carla oh torx torx is what i was thinking of it stands for the open racing car simulator and torx was designed for ai like you could actually you could play it but it's really meant for ai to play it nice so i was gonna say that that if you want to get down to the that
对于休闲阅读来说。所以这个 PDF 是一个很好的入门，我想向它致敬。但也只是谈谈，就像 Jason 所说的，工具箱里一个有用的工具，它出现在令人惊讶的许多地方。简而言之，PID 控制器是一个缩写，代表比例（Proportional）、积分（Integral）、微分（Derivative）。也就是说，你想要在输出中达到某个值，比如你在加热一壶水，里面有一个温度计，你在控制下面的加热器。如果你把下面的线圈开到全功率，水不会瞬间沸腾，
specific cut of the problem may get you there faster than writing mario kart from scratch oh yeah totally i mean i think you know uh the mario kart from scratch you would make just like a really fake physics engine and just really silly. But yeah, if you wanted to, you know, ultimately control a real car, if you wanted to ladder up to that, then yeah, Torx would be a good starting point or Carla would be another one. So my next news article unintentionally, I guess, is it's a piece of what you might use to kind of get there. And that is something called a control loop or a controller and sort of figuring out, you know, given some observations of the real world, you know, affect some output. And you can get as fancy or non-fancy of these words as you want. I'm pretty non-fancy.
如果你看过一壶水的话。如果它能那样做就好了，但它不会。所以你有一个想要达到的温度，你有一个提供反馈的温度计，这里有延迟。当你接近目标时，你想开始降低功率，这样你就不会超过你的温度。因为如果你在做饭……好吧，我说了水，但如果你在水里煮东西，你不想让它过热，比如烧焦食物之类的，过热的等价物……你知道，你可以设置这个，
And that is, I call it PID controller. So the article I have here is PID without a PhD. Jason was telling us at the pre-show he says pid which i've heard before as well so uh we'll have to ask the ai which one is correct um but pid without a phd is a is a little pdf with uh i will say not the most elementary explanation but without getting into my background makes it such that if you just, you know, look at the Wikipedia page for PID controller, you're quickly going to get masked out. Well, that's not good grammar. Oh, well, you're going to get into math over your head, or at least math I'm not comfortable
无需深入探讨，比例、积分和微分项将帮助你控制行为，尽可能快地达到目标，并在你对输入有潜在反应时保持良好的行为。这是一种控制回路，因为你坐在那里一遍又一遍地循环，测量，将测量结果控制在你想要的输出值，决定你想要对设置做什么。它们从这里开始增长，这是最琐碎的一种，你可以用 PID 控制器做各种更高级的优化，最终甚至转向其他控制器，一旦你超越了琐碎的事情。甚至围绕这篇文章的在线讨论也有很多关于 PID 是否在 99% 的情况下都还可以，
with for like a casual reading. And so this PDF is a great introduction, and did want to give a shout out to it. But also just to talk about, about i guess similar to what jason is saying a useful tool in the toolbox that kind of pops up in a surprising number of places and so just in brief a pid controller is an acronym stands for proportional integral derivative and that is that you have some value you want to achieve in your output say you're heating a pot of water and you have a thermometer in it and you're controlling the heater underneath. If you crank the coil underneath all the way to full power, the water is not gonna instantaneously boil
还是它是最糟糕的东西，因为它不是最优解。我的看法是，它是一个很好的工具箱工具，也是学习的好东西。通常有很多事情你想应用某种方式，从 A 到 B，但在受控响应中，它最终属于同一类问题。所以意识到这些事情，了解在不熟悉的领域如何操作是很好的。是的，如果我没记错的话，我没读过这篇文章，但我认为 P 基本上是你离目标有多远。I 是最近发生了什么，D 是你更像……你知道，如果你正冲向终点线，那么那个比例最好非常大。否则，你必须开始减速。这就是微分的作用。如果你来回摇摆，很明显你需要减速，因为你已经连续六七次超过目标了，这就是积分的作用。即使是设置这些值也有一整套理论，如果你使用 PID 控制器来设置这些值，天哪，我看不出这怎么会变成递归，
if you've ever watched a pot of water. It would be nice if it did that, but it doesn't. And so you have some temperature you're trying to achieve and you have the thermometer that's giving you feedback, there's you know this latency and as you get closer you want to start modulating the power down so you don't necessarily like overshoot your temperature um you know because if you were cooking well now i said water but if you were cooking something in the water that you know you didn't want to be overheated like burn your food or whatever the equivalent of over overheating it would be um you know you don't you can set this
栈溢出。我想，一旦你了解了这些，你就会注意到，比如你车里的巡航控制，它是如何表现的。你可以考虑一下，不一定他们是这样做的，但你也会开始看到一些……如果你有 3D 打印机，它不会知道底部加热床或喷出塑料的部分有多少质量。所以通常你会看到，当你打开它时，它会进行一些校准。
without going into it the proportional integral and derivative terms that will help you to kind of control the behavior of getting to as quickly as possible and then sort of having good behavior as you sort of have this uh latent response to your inputs and this is a form of a control loop because you're kind of sitting there looping over and over again, take the measurement, control the measurement to what you want the output to be decide what you, you know, want to do to your to your, your settings. And so they they grow from here, it's kind of the most, you know, trivial one, there's all sorts of more advanced optimizations that you can do with PID controllers, and then ultimately even moving on to other controllers, once you get past sort of like the trivial things. And even the online discussion around this article had a lot of debate about whether PID is sort of 99% of the time, okay,
校准的一部分是加热、冷却、加热、冷却，以了解这些设备在当前配置和当前环境下的响应，并设置这些 PID 控制器的参数。是的。是的。这说得通。
or whether it's the worst thing ever, because it just, you know, it's just not the most optimal answer. My take is, you know, it's a good tool in the toolbox and learning. And there are often things where you want to apply some sort of, know move from a to b but in a controlled response and it it sort of ends up being in the same bucket of problems i will say and so being aware of these things is uh it's good to know your way around in unfamiliar territory yeah if i remember correctly and i haven't read this article but i think the the P is basically how far away from the target you are. The I is what has happened recently, and the D is your kind of more Like, you know, if you're, if you're screaming towards the finish line, then that proportion better be really big. Otherwise, you have to start slowing down. So that's where the derivative comes in. And if you're if you're waffling back and forth, that it's clear that like you need to slow down because you've overshot six, seven times a row and that's where the integral comes in even setting the values has a whole bucket of uh theories around and it is really interesting if you use a pit controller to set the values gee i can't see where this might become recursive
非常酷。是的，大家一定要读一下。我的意思是，PID 控制器正如 Patrick 所说，是最简单的东西，它在每个房子里，它是你所有的恒温器。它几乎肯定在使用 PID，也许现在不是了，我想，但是的。但如果你有那种老式的霍尼韦尔恒温器，无论如何……但绝对值得学习，我认为这是一个很好的基础。好吧，我的新闻故事是 Google 发布了 Gemma。所以，大多数人都听说过 Llama，Llama 是 Facebook 的开源 LLM。有人做了一个项目叫 llama.cpp，这是一个很奇怪的项目名称，但基本上它是一种非常快速运行这些 Llama 模型的方法。没有
uh stack overflow um i i think that if you uh once you learn about these you will notice like you know cruise control in your car and how does it behave uh you know you can sort of think about this not necessarily that they do it but you'll start to see also some um if you have like a 3d printer or as an example it will not know how much kind of like mass the heating the heated bed has at the bottom or the part that squirts out the plastic. So often you'll see during, when you're turning it on, it'll do some calibration.
PyTorch，他们加载了 PyTorch 模型，但一切都是用 C++ 完成的，并且针对所有这些不同的架构进行了超级、超级定制和优化。它达到了这样的程度：在你的 MacBook 上，你可以几乎实时地运行这些大语言模型。所以这非常令人兴奋。由此产生了很多研究。
And part of its calibration is heating, cooling, heating, cooling to understand the response of those devices in their current configuration and their current environment and setting the parameters of these PID controllers. Yep. Yep. That makes sense.
所以 Google 发布了 Gemma。这也是一个争论领域。但好吧，基本上 Gemma 模型也是那些足够小、可以在本地运行的模型。事实上，他们甚至有一个比最小的 Llama 模型还要小的模型。因此，它可以在更少的硬件上运行，比如在你的手机上实时运行。他们声称性能要好得多。这是一个很大的争论，因为他们的方式……这有点陷入细节了，但你知道，如果你看 Llama 7B 或 Gemma 7B，那个 7B 数字意味着 70 亿，所以有 70 亿个参数
Very cool. Yeah, folks definitely read i mean pid controller is is is as patrick says like the simplest thing it's in every house it's all your thermostat uh you know it's almost certainly using a pid maybe not nowadays i think but yeah yeah i mean but if you have like one of these old honeywell ones you know whatever um but uh definitely worth learning about i think it's it's a great foundation um all right my new story is google releasing gemma so um most people have heard about llama um llama is this open source llm from facebook um someone uh made a project called llama.cpp which is kind of a weird name of a project but basically it's a way to run these llama models really fast um there's no
在模型中，有 70 亿个权重需要调整。每当你执行模型来生成一个 token 时，你至少必须使用所有那 70 亿个权重。所以，那个数字越小，你必须使用的权重就越少，一切就越快。现在问题是，这不仅仅是……它不是一维的，对吧？所以 Gemma 模型有更大的嵌入（embedding），我不会在这里深入细节，这不太相关，但基本上因为它们有如此大的嵌入大小，它们可能比相同大小的 Llama 模型慢得多。但它们也可以表现得更好。所以围绕着
pytorch um they're loading the pytorch model um but it's all done in C++ and everything is super, super customized and optimized for all these different architectures. And it gets to the point where like on your MacBook, you can run these large language models almost in real time. And so that's been really exciting. There's been a whole ton of research that's come out of that.
“我们在 70 亿参数下表现更好”有一些广告宣传。但酷的是，这是一整套新的开源模型，我们可以使用。最有趣的大语言模型之一，你可以在普通硬件上运行的是这个叫 Mixtral 的模型，我想他们混合了几个不同的开源模型来制作一个类似监督者的模型。我认为这很迷人。
So Google released Gemma. This is also kind of an area of debate. But okay, well, just basically the Gemma models are also these models that are small enough that you could run them locally. In fact, they even have one even smaller than the smallest Lama model. So as a result, it can run on even less hardware like maybe on your phone in real time um they claim the performance is you know much better um there's a big debate because the way they're kind of um it kind of gets in the weeds here but you know the the the seven if you look at like the llama 7b or gemma 7b that that 7b number means 7 billion so there's 7 billion parameters
所以现在你有另一个模型可以加入这个组合，字面意思。所以我认为这里有很多潜力，大家应该去看看。Llama.cpp，尽管项目名称如此，实际上运行了很多这些开源模型。我相信他们正在疯狂工作。当这个播客发布时，他们会将 Gemma 模型放入 Llama.cpp，这样你就可以在你的笔记本电脑上运行它们了。所以绝对值得一看。参数的数量是否也与使用它所需的内存量有关？因为这是他们总是大做文章的事情之一，不仅仅是需要 GPU，而是
in the model 7 billion weights that have to be tuned and um whenever you execute the model to generate a token you have to you have to at least use all of those seven billion weights um so you know the smaller that number gets the less weight you have to use the faster everything gets um now the problem is like that's not the only uh it's not so one-dimensional right so the gemma models have a much larger embedding and i'm not gonna get too much in details here it's not it's not like that relevant but basically because they have such a large embedding size um they could be a lot slower than the llama model of the same size. But they can also perform better. So there's a little bit of advertising talk around the,
需要具有非常大内存的 GPU。是的。所以有一堆技巧你可以做。他们已经达到了进行 4 位量化的程度，所以他们只允许每个权重成为 16 个不同值中的一个。但这就是那个 Llama.cpp 项目，这是他们做的事情之一。但你是对的，参数越多，运行模型所需的 CPU RAM 或视频 RAM 就越多。非常酷。那么，或者也许我们可以继续，但微调，这些模型的微调……有些模型更容易微调吗？所以训练……运行和执行它们，大概像 Google 出品的 Gemma 与你可以在网上直接使用的那些有关。所以如果你没有互联网连接之类的，它感觉很有用，而且是开源的。但对我来说，力量，我想你之前谈过尝试那个，是添加你自己的输入并进行一些额外的训练或切换或定制。当涉及到那个方面时，这些模型是等价的吗？还是有些更好，有些更差？是的，所以 Gemma 和 Llama 之间的巨大区别是 Gemma 的嵌入层非常巨大。所以，我们实际上会在本集的后面讨论这个，但基本上嵌入层是你从理解你刚才说的话切换到决定接下来要说什么的层。所以那一层非常重要，而在 Gemma 中那一层非常巨大。所以我预计微调它会更难，仅仅因为这个原因，需要更多的数据，更多的迭代。
oh, we perform better at 7 billion. But the cool thing is, you know, it's a whole new set of open source models that we have at our disposal. One of the most interesting large language models that have come out that you could run on commodity hardware is this one called mix drill where i think they mixed several different open source models to make one kind of supervisor model um and uh and i think that's fascinating
哦，我们在70亿参数规模下表现得更好。但很酷的一点是，我们现在有一整套全新的开源模型可供使用。目前出现的最有趣的大型语言模型之一，就是那个可以在普通硬件上运行的名为Mixtral的模型，我想他们混合了几个不同的开源模型来构建一个类似于监督者的模型，这非常令人着迷。
and so now you have another model you can add to the mix, literally. So I think there's a lot of potential here and folks should check it out. The llama.cpp, despite the project name, actually runs a lot of these open source models. And I'm sure they're feverishly working. By the time this podcast is out, they'll have the gemma models in llama.cpp so you could run them on your on your laptop so um definitely something to check out is the number of parameters also like uh sort of related to how much memory it takes to use because that's one of the things that that they always make a big deal about is like not just needing a gpu but
所以现在你又多了一个可以加入混合的模型，字面意义上的混合。我认为这里潜力巨大，大家应该去看看。llama.cpp尽管项目名称如此，实际上可以运行许多这类开源模型。我相信他们正在紧张地工作，等这期播客发布时，他们应该已经把Gemma模型加入到llama.cpp中了，这样你就可以在自己的笔记本电脑上运行它们。所以，参数数量是否也与使用时所需的内存大小有关？因为这是他们总是强调的一点，不仅仅是需要GPU，而是
a gpu with like very large amounts of memory yep yep and so there's uh a bunch of tricks you can do um they got to the point where they're doing four bit quantization um so they're only allowing each weight to be one of 16 different values um but uh that's what that llama.cpp uh project that's one of the things they do but you're right you know the more parameters the more either cpu ram or video ram you need to to run the model very cool and then does it or maybe we can we move on but fine tuning fine tuning of these like is it some models are easier to fine tune like so the training so running them and executing them presumably like jemma coming from google is related to you know the ones that you can just go online and use so if you don't have an internet connection or something it feels useful and being open source but to me the power and i think you've talked
还需要拥有非常大内存的GPU。没错，确实如此。所以有很多技巧可以使用，他们已经做到了四位量化，也就是说他们只允许每个权重取16个不同值中的一个。这就是llama.cpp项目所做的事情之一。但你是对的，参数越多，运行模型所需的CPU内存或显存就越多。非常酷。那么，我们是否可以继续讨论微调？这些模型中是否有些更容易微调？运行和执行它们，比如来自谷歌的Gemma，与你可以在线使用的那些模型相关。所以如果你没有互联网连接，这感觉很有用，而且它是开源的。但对我来说，其力量在于——我想你之前也谈到过
about trying that before is like adding your own inputs and doing some you know additional training or switching or customization to um are these ones equivalent when it comes to that aspect or is like some are better for that and some are worse yeah so the the big difference between jemma and llama is the embedding layer of jemma is enormous um so and we'll talk about this actually later in this episode but but basically the embedding layer is the layer where you switch from understanding what you just said to deciding what to say next and so that that layer is really important um and so that layer is enormous in gemma so i would expect it to be harder to fine tune just because of that, to require more data, more iterations.
尝试过这一点——即添加你自己的输入并进行一些额外的训练、切换或定制。在这一方面，这些模型是等效的吗？还是说有些模型在这方面更好，有些更差？是的，Gemma和Llama之间的巨大区别在于Gemma的嵌入层非常庞大。我们稍后会在本期节目中讨论这一点，但基本上嵌入层是决定从理解你刚才所说的话到决定接下来要说什么的转换层，所以这一层非常重要。Gemma的这一层非常巨大，所以我预计它会更难微调，因为这需要更多的数据和更多的迭代。
But in general, yes, I mean, it's much easier to fine tune the 7 billion model than the 70 billion. The other challenge about fine tuning is you can't do quantization while you're training. And so now you need to store the 32 bit or maybe even 64 bit potentially float for each weight um and so that gets that gets really expensive so that's where you need like the 64 gig gpu to do the training uh this is a fascinating time fascinating time i'm excited need to learn here good thing we have a topic queued up for this yeah you could start a large language model startup but i think
但总的来说，是的，我的意思是，微调70亿参数的模型比700亿参数的模型要容易得多。微调的另一个挑战是你在训练时无法进行量化。因此，现在你需要为每个权重存储32位甚至可能是64位的浮点数，这会变得非常昂贵，所以这就是为什么你需要像64GB显存的GPU来进行训练。这是一个迷人的时代，迷人的时代，我很兴奋，需要在这里学习。好在我们已经排好了一个话题，是的，你可以创办一家大语言模型初创公司，但我认为
they took all the names there's no names left in the entire language there's so many of them all right time for book of the show all right what's your book of the show mine is the eye of the world by robert j which is the first book in the wheel of time series. I guess I'm, I'm late to this, you know, classic fantasy. Most people probably already heard of this. Also, if you have not seen any of the large amounts of advertisement, Amazon prime has done for Amazon prime video. They have a wheel of time series, a tv series i guess it's called oh cool um and so
他们把所有的名字都占用了，整个语言里已经没有剩下的名字了，名字太多了。好了，现在是本期推荐书目的时间。好了，你推荐什么书？我推荐的是罗伯特·乔丹的《世界之眼》，这是《时光之轮》系列的第一本书。我想我对此了解得太晚了，你知道，这是经典的奇幻作品。大多数人可能已经听说过它了。另外，如果你还没有看到亚马逊Prime为亚马逊Prime视频投放的大量广告，他们有一部《时光之轮》系列剧，我想是叫这个名字，哦，酷，所以
that's actually i had long known about this uh we talked a lot about brandon sanderson books and brandon sanderson and ends up writing the ending of the wheel of time uh book series because oh i didn't know that jordan passes passed away before the series could be completed. So he left his notes and Brandon Sanderson sort of released it. So very adjacent to this series, which is never, if you've ever seen the books, they're intimidatingly large. So they're being,
其实我早就知道这个了，我们谈论了很多布兰登·桑德森的书，布兰登·桑德森最终写了《时光之轮》系列丛书的结局，因为哦，我不知道乔丹在系列完成之前就去世了。所以他留下了笔记，布兰登·桑德森算是把它发布了。所以与这个系列非常相关，如果你见过这些书，它们大得令人望而生畏。所以它们正在被，
you know, I don't, I should have looked at, I think there's 12 of them, but being there so many, you know, I was always a little intimidated to pick it up, but I actually really enjoyed the TV show.
你知道，我不，我应该查一下，我想有12本，但因为数量太多，你知道，我一直有点不敢去读，但我实际上真的很喜欢这部电视剧。
I've watched there's two seasons now and decided it's finally time to pick the book up being aware that, you know, books and TV shows are not necessarily the same thing. But but interesting enough in the world, and, you know, seeing some conversations, I guess, Brandon Sanderson is actually one of the consultants for the Wheel of Time show. And, you know, you see arguments. Oh, I guess I'm nerdy. But in the parts of the internet that we all spend time on, you'll see people kind of debating about the Wheel of Time time show. And so it piqued my interest.
我已经看了，现在有两季了，决定终于到了读这本书的时候了，虽然我知道书和电视剧不一定是一回事。但在这个世界里很有趣，而且，你知道，看到一些讨论，我想，布兰登·桑德森实际上是《时光之轮》剧集的顾问之一。而且，你知道，你会看到争论。哦，我想我是个书呆子。但在我们大家都花时间泡的互联网部分，你会看到人们在争论《时光之轮》剧集。所以这激起了我的兴趣。
And so now I have to like know for myself and, you know, go look at the book so I can judge if the TV series is a good reflection of the book or not. Very cool. I read this book probably when i was like 14 or something oh but you've not seen the tv series i've not i didn't even know there was one until you just mentioned oh no i'm going to have to catch up i'm one of those people that i don't watch tv but i do watch youtube um and uh i watch premium, so I only get the ads that the creators, you know, actually put in themselves.
所以现在我必须亲自去了解，你知道，去看看书，这样我才能判断电视剧是否是对原著的良好反映。非常酷。我大概在14岁左右读过这本书，哦，但你还没看过电视剧？我没有，我甚至不知道有这部剧，直到你刚才提到。哦不，我得去补一下。我属于那种不看电视但看YouTube的人，而且，我订阅了高级会员，所以我只会看到创作者自己放入的广告。
Um, but, uh, yeah, actually you would, you would, you and I would probably have very similar YouTube interests lately. I've been binging on this guy, black tail studio who makes coffee tables. Have you seen this guy? Yeah. Um, but yeah, I, I don't have, I have Amazon prime, prime but i've never watched watched videos on it but i will check that out that sounds cool uh so my new my new so so sorry on a side topic here watching youtube a lot i have uh apparently like too many interests slash hobbies that youtube
嗯，但是，是的，实际上你，你和我最近可能有非常相似的YouTube兴趣。我一直在狂看这个叫Blacktail Studio的家伙，他制作咖啡桌。你见过这个人吗？是的。嗯，但是是的，我，我没有，我有亚马逊Prime，但我从来没在上面看过视频，但我会去看看，听起来很酷。所以我的新，我的新，抱歉，这里跑题了，因为经常看YouTube，我显然有太多的兴趣爱好，以至于YouTube
doesn't like it's not able to hold them all in its you know recommended video list so i have subscriptions of course but like if i go to my front page, like whatever certain topics, if I ever watch a video, so we were talking about power world, I watched a video about power world instantly. Like my whole feed became like two thirds dominated by power world. Um, and I had to like go remove watching power world videos from my watch history to like get back to any semblance. But in just in in general as i like rotate through my interests that like i noticed that it it feels like it can't hold them all and it's like you know consideration matrix or whatever however it's doing you know not to anthropomorphize it but
无法在它的推荐视频列表中容纳所有这些，所以我当然有订阅，但如果我进入首页，无论什么特定主题，如果我看了某个视频，比如我们刚才谈论的《幻兽帕鲁》，我立刻看了一个关于《幻兽帕鲁》的视频。就像我的整个信息流有三分之二被《幻兽帕鲁》占据了。嗯，我不得不去从观看历史中删除观看《幻兽帕鲁》视频的记录，才能恢复到某种样子。但总的来说，随着我轮换我的兴趣，我注意到它似乎无法容纳所有这些，就像在它的考虑矩阵中，或者无论它是怎么做的，你知道，不是要拟人化它，但
it just feels like yeah if i yeah once you once you move to a new thing you get lots of videos about that and you stop getting videos about the other even if you were watching them when offered and so i don't know maybe that's a personal problem just because i i should focus but well i think it just yeah there's a movement of the masses there like like probably people get on a topic and binge it and then that changes the behavior of the system for everybody else you know um my book of the show is how to make a video game all by yourself uh this is a very short book um extremely useful book i've been going to over the past you know since since covid let up a bit um i've been going to a lot of
感觉就是，一旦你转向一个新事物，你就会得到很多关于那个的视频，而你不再得到关于其他的视频，即使你在被推荐时也看了它们。所以我不知道，也许这是一个个人问题，只是因为我应该专注。但我认为这只是大众的趋势，就像人们可能迷上一个话题并狂看，然后这改变了系统对其他所有人的行为，你知道。嗯，我本期的推荐书目是《如何独自制作一款电子游戏》，这是一本非常短的书，非常实用的书。自从新冠疫情稍微缓解以来，我一直在读，
video game developer meetups as people know i made this ai hero game but i've also been talking to a lot of other game developers in the area and one thing i've noticed is a lot of them don't see themselves as producers a lot of them are software engineers and they end up with like a really cool tech demo or engine this one guy built this um thing where it was like kind of like a minecraft world but you had uh you had rocket launchers for arms and every rocket actually caused a crater in the world and so you flew around like blowing craters in the world and they even had the water working so like if you if you're underground and you blew a hole up and you accidentally blew a hole into the bottom of the ocean like water would just start filling in it was cool i mean i was super impressed um and and as the water filled
我参加了很多电子游戏开发者的聚会，正如人们所知，我制作了这个AI英雄游戏，但我还与该地区的许多其他游戏开发者交谈过。我注意到的一件事是，他们中的许多人并不把自己视为制作人，他们中的许多人是软件工程师，他们最终做出了一个非常酷的技术演示或引擎。有一个家伙构建了这个东西，它有点像《我的世界》世界，但你的手臂上有火箭发射器，每一枚火箭实际上都会在世界中造成一个弹坑，所以你飞来飞去，在世界中炸出弹坑，他们甚至让水也能工作，所以如果你在地下，你炸开一个洞，不小心炸到了海底，水就会开始涌入，这很酷。我的意思是，我印象非常深刻，而且随着水填满
in like voxels of air like floated up. So he had naturally had bubbles like you didn't have to like, you know, design the bubble separately. It was fascinating. But what it wasn't was it was not a game, you know, like I had a lot of fun, but I wouldn't say I was playing a game. I would say maybe I was it was more of like an art kind of thing. Um, and, uh, I feel like this book would have been perfect for this person because, um, it really, it starts off with the first principle of like, you are a video game producer. And so it lists all these things that ultimately don't really matter. Um, like which engine you pick or these other things right or
像空气体素一样浮上来。所以他自然地有了气泡，你不需要单独设计气泡。这太迷人了。但它不是一个游戏，你知道，虽然我玩得很开心，但我不会说我在玩游戏。我会说也许它更像是一种艺术品。嗯，我觉得这本书对这个人来说会很完美，因为，嗯，它从第一原则开始，比如，你是一名电子游戏制作人。所以它列出了所有最终并不重要的事情，比如你选择哪个引擎或其他这些事情，或者
they're they're secondary to your to the goal um i thought it was really well written um i didn't bother to research the author but i'm assuming it's somebody who's done a bunch of indie games um and uh yeah it was a short read but I had a lot of fun. That sounds cool. I, I fascinated by this as well. I, one day I should go to a video game meetup. That actually sounds like it'd be really cool. I feel like it's a blast and I would start writing video games. It's a total blast.
它们对你的目标来说是次要的。我觉得它写得非常好，我没有费心去研究作者，但我假设是一个做过很多独立游戏的人。而且，是的，这是一本短读物，但我玩得很开心。听起来很酷。我也对此很着迷。有一天我应该去参加一个电子游戏聚会。那听起来真的很酷。我觉得这会很有趣，我会开始写电子游戏。这绝对很有趣。
I've met some really nice people there. Very cool. Time for tool of the show. All right. So I'm up first again, my tool is not so much about the tool, but just a shout out that like, I wish more companies kind of did this thing. So we talked about it a while ago. And I recently used this tool. And that is Google released an unlock tool for their online streaming gaming service stadia which shut down
我在那里遇到了一些非常好的人。非常酷。现在是本期工具时间。好的。这次又是我先来，我的工具与其说是关于工具，不如说是一个呼吁，我希望更多的公司能做这种事。我们前段时间谈过它。我最近使用了这个工具。那就是谷歌为他们的在线流媒体游戏服务Stadia发布了一个解锁工具，该服务已经关闭了。
and they had run sales where you could get a chromecast and a stadia controller which is what you needed to play stadia games and the stadia controller interestingly connects straight to wi-fi so you are wi-fi controlling your server box in the cloud that is running your game and then the results of the video would stream down to your chromecast and onto your tv and so you were not interacting you may be sitting in front of your tv but you could have been from another city you know playing your video game on the tv in your house or whatever and it wouldn't care because your controller just connects up to the internet via wi-fi um and then you know happens to control troll's device and there were some ui loops to you know if you had multiple to make sure that you were controlling the right
他们曾经进行过促销，你可以买到一个Chromecast和一个Stadia手柄，这是玩Stadia游戏所必需的。Stadia手柄有趣的地方在于它直接连接到Wi-Fi，所以你是通过Wi-Fi控制云端运行你游戏的服务器盒子，然后视频结果会流式传输到你的Chromecast并显示在你的电视上。所以你不是在交互，你可能坐在电视机前，但你可能来自另一个城市，在家里或其他地方的电视上玩你的电子游戏，它不在乎，因为你的手柄只是通过Wi-Fi连接到互联网。然后，你知道，碰巧控制了设备。而且有一些UI循环，如果你有多个，要确保你控制的是正确的
tv and that kind of thing but they kept running specials trying to get people to sign up for their service and i just wanted the chromecast so i ended up having a number of the stadia controllers laying around but there's nothing really do with them because they connect to bluetooth and the service shut down so they released uh on the radio chip that they had in there it also had bluetooth so they released a a website that you can plug your controller in follow the on-screen instructions and will basically install a new firmware that removes the wi-fi and adds bluetooth connectivity just use it as a bluetooth gamepad oh nice play on your steam deck i paired it to my steam deck and play it on my steam deck or my computer as well um lots of things have bluetooth these days so it's really easy to use as a game controller and i just thought they didn't need to do that like it it was custom
电视之类的东西。但他们一直在进行促销，试图让人们注册他们的服务，而我只是想要那个Chromecast，所以我最终留下了很多Stadia手柄。但它们真的没什么用，因为它们连接到蓝牙，而且服务关闭了。所以他们发布了，在他们拥有的无线电芯片上，它也有蓝牙。所以他们发布了一个网站，你可以插入你的手柄，按照屏幕上的说明操作，它基本上会安装一个新的固件，移除Wi-Fi并添加蓝牙连接，只需将其用作蓝牙游戏手柄。哦，不错，在你的Steam Deck上玩。我把它配对到了我的Steam Deck上，也在我的Steam Deck或电脑上玩。嗯，现在很多东西都有蓝牙，所以作为游戏手柄使用非常容易。我只是觉得他们没必要这样做，因为它是为他们的东西定制的
hardware for their thing but they found a way that was like easy enough for them and straightforward to kind of do this and it's if you if if you're like me you probably have a drawer full of things that correspond to services which are dead and not able to be used anymore and so it's not always possible i understand the complexities of it but it would be really cool to see this be like a thing that people try to do like at least give some functionality to devices when they reach their sort of end of service life yeah totally um yeah that's that's amazing yeah now i kind of wish i had bought some of these maybe you can get them on sale on ebay or something i don't know if
硬件，但他们找到了一种对他们来说足够简单直接的方法来做到这一点。如果你像我一样，你可能有一个抽屉里装满了对应于已经死亡且无法再使用的服务的物品。所以这并不总是可能的，我理解其中的复杂性，但如果能看到这成为人们尝试做的事情，那会非常酷，至少在设备达到服务寿命终点时赋予它们一些功能。是的，完全同意。嗯，是的，这太棒了。现在我有点后悔没买一些，也许你可以在eBay或其他地方打折买到它们，我不知道
they went up in price or down in price after this i've not followed the ebay price trajectory all right my tool of the show is uh fuse and sshfs this is one of these kind of table stakes things where it's really good to have this in your toolbox i use this recently um i guess just a recap so fuse is a way for it stands for like file system in user space, something like that. I don't know. I'm not sure if I'm getting that totally right. But basically, it's a way for you to mount a file system without being the root user. And so, you know, if you're logging into a system at work, you probably don't have the
在这次之后它们的价格是涨了还是跌了，我没有关注eBay的价格轨迹。好的，我本期的工具是Fuse和sshfs。这是那种基础性的东西，把它放在你的工具箱里真的很好。我最近用了这个。我想只是回顾一下，Fuse是一种方式，它代表用户空间文件系统，类似这样的东西。我不知道。我不确定我是否完全正确。但基本上，这是一种让你在不是root用户的情况下挂载文件系统的方法。所以，你知道，如果你在工作中登录系统，你可能没有
root account. And so you need to use something like Fuse. Even if you're doing something in your house where you do have root access it could be cumbersome to like have to sudo all the time and put in the root password and all that you might just want to mount a directory um just right there you know as a sub directory of your home directory um like imagine mounting your google drive or something like that you want that to just happen you don't want to have to put in your root password um so fuse lets you do that um so sshfs is interesting thing where um you know you can you can ssh into a machine and and you have now remote access you can run an editor do all that stuff um there's also something called SCP where it uses SSH,
root账户。所以你需要使用像Fuse这样的东西。即使你在家里做一些你有root访问权限的事情，一直sudo并输入root密码也可能很麻烦，你可能只是想挂载一个目录，就在那里，作为你主目录的一个子目录。比如想象挂载你的Google Drive之类的东西，你希望它就这样发生，你不想必须输入你的root密码。所以Fuse让你做到这一点。所以sshfs是一个有趣的东西，你知道，你可以ssh进入一台机器，现在你有了远程访问权限，你可以运行编辑器做所有这些事情。还有一种叫SCP的东西，它使用SSH，
but instead of giving you a pseudo terminal, it gives you a file. So you can take a file from that remote computer and put it on your computer. So you can like SCP, foo.txt, my home directory, and it'll actually, or sorry, SCP, user at server colon foo.txt and so i'll actually go to that server find the foo.txt file bring it to your computer that's okay but it could
但它不是给你一个伪终端，而是给你一个文件。所以你可以从那台远程计算机上拿一个文件并把它放到你的电脑上。所以你可以像SCP，foo.txt，我的主目录，它实际上会，或者抱歉，SCP，用户@服务器:foo.txt，它实际上会去那台服务器找到foo.txt文件并把它带到你的电脑上。这还可以，但它可能
be kind of cumbersome i was having a situation where i was creating files on a remote computer and i was wanting to look at them on my laptop and work pretty quickly i didn't want to have to keep copying them to the laptop and all of that also the files were kind of big and i only needed to look at the first part of them etc so um so i just set up this shfs uh. And so I mounted a directory on the target computer as a directory on my laptop. And I could just look at all of those files. I could read the first 100 kilobytes or 10 megabytes of the file without having to copy the whole thing. It worked well.
有点麻烦。我当时的情况是，我在远程计算机上创建文件，我想在我的笔记本电脑上快速查看它们。我不想一直把它们复制到笔记本电脑上，而且文件有点大，我只需要查看它们的前半部分等等。所以，我就设置了这个sshfs。然后我把目标计算机上的一个目录挂载为我笔记本电脑上的一个目录。我就可以查看所有这些文件。我可以读取文件的前100KB或10MB，而无需复制整个文件。它工作得很好。
The challenge is if your laptop goes to sleep, just like any SSH connection, when it comes back, the file system's like broken. You have to unmount it or remount it. So, you know, it's not perfect, but it's extremely useful, especially at a pinch.
挑战在于，如果你的笔记本电脑进入睡眠状态，就像任何SSH连接一样，当它回来时，文件系统就像坏了一样。你必须卸载它或重新挂载它。所以，你知道，它并不完美，但它非常有用，尤其是在紧急情况下。
And it's one of these things that's almost ubiquitous because almost any machine you can SSsh into so you're only required to install things on your local machine i didn't know you were going to talk about this i didn't know this is i actually used this for the first time a couple days ago no way interestingly uh there is a windows version as well that will allow you to mount another linux computer over ssh to a drive letter in windows and i was on a windows computer and my i wanted to copy some files from my steam
而且它是那种几乎无处不在的东西，因为几乎任何机器你都可以SSH进去，所以你只需要在本地机器上安装东西。我不知道你要谈论这个，我不知道这是，我实际上几天前第一次使用它。不会吧，有趣的是，还有一个Windows版本，它允许你通过SSH将另一台Linux计算机挂载到Windows中的驱动器号。我当时在一台Windows计算机上，我想从我的Steam
deck memory card which is ext3 formatted so my windows computer couldn't see it well don't ask anyways long story anyways but the steam deck allows you to just enable SSH pretty easily. So I just did that. And this was the path. The path was to basically turn on SSH file system, have it on Windows show up as a mount. And then I could have used, I actually did later, end up using the SCP method you talked about.
Deck存储卡中复制一些文件，它是ext3格式的，所以我的Windows计算机看不到它。好吧，别问了，反正长话短说，Steam Deck允许你很容易地启用SSH。所以我只是那样做了。这就是路径。路径基本上是打开SSH文件系统，让它在Windows上显示为一个挂载点。然后我可以使用，我后来确实用了，最终使用了你谈到的SCP方法。
It was a little cleaner. But mounting as a file system was also something that was eminently doable. And then other applications could have pointed at it. So it has this advantages. But yeah, so I did end up using, as you said, so many things have SSH on them, or you can SSH into, and if you can, and it has files, this is a good way of getting access to those files. Yeah, totally. to those files yeah totally um all right let's jump into transformers and large language models
它稍微干净一点。但作为文件系统挂载也是完全可行的。然后其他应用程序可以指向它。所以它有这个优势。但是的，所以我最终使用了，正如你所说，很多东西都有SSH，或者你可以SSH进去，如果可以，而且它有文件，这是获取这些文件的好方法。是的，完全同意。获取这些文件，是的，完全同意。嗯，好的，让我们进入Transformer和大语言模型。
um yeah i mean there's it's one of these things it's actually agoraphobic like there's so much content and so topical but but um we'll start with the basics, which is how neural networks store information. If you don't know what a neural network is, we actually had some AI, an AI two-part series. It's a bit dated, but it covers that in pretty good detail. But basically, you have these layers, and each layer you do a bunch of dot products. This almost becomes like a tensor product to produce the next layer. And so the weights, the things that you're multiplying by, you can change those as part of training this model. And by default, it goes from one layer to the next to the next.
嗯，是的，我的意思是，这是那种实际上让人感到广场恐惧症的东西，因为内容太多且非常热门，但嗯，我们将从基础开始，即神经网络如何存储信息。如果你不知道什么是神经网络，我们实际上有一个AI，一个AI两部分系列。它有点过时，但它非常详细地涵盖了这一点。但基本上，你有这些层，每一层你做一堆点积。这几乎变成了张量积来产生下一层。所以权重，你乘以的东西，你可以在训练这个模型时改变它们。默认情况下，它从一层到下一层再到下一层。
Think of it as like a DAG, right? And by default, you know, it goes from one layer to the next to the next is like this. Think of it as like a DAG, right? And it can split and it can rejoin and there's convolutions. But effectively, it's acyclic. It just goes in one direction and then it ends with some target. You compare that target to your expected value for that target and you use that difference to adjust all the weights um now you know people very quickly wanted a way to store information they wanted these neural networks to be stateful you know imagine if you are training a neural net to solve a maze. If it's the same maze every time, you could just train the neural net to
把它想象成一个DAG，对吧？默认情况下，你知道，它从一层到下一层再到下一层是这样的。把它想象成一个DAG，对吧？它可以分裂，可以重新连接，还有卷积。但实际上，它是无环的。它只是朝一个方向走，然后以某个目标结束。你将该目标与该目标的预期值进行比较，并使用该差异来调整所有权重。嗯，现在你知道，人们很快就想要一种存储信息的方法，他们想要这些神经网络是有状态的。你知道，想象一下如果你正在训练一个神经网络来解决迷宫。如果每次都是同一个迷宫，你只需训练神经网络来
solve that maze and the weights of the neural net will just hold really specific information about that maze. Like, oh, when I see this intersection, turn left. But if you wanted to train a generic neural network to solve any maze and to to you know solve it over time it has to keep a representation of the maze in the neural network right and so it's it's a memory that is sort of online that's independent of training um so this is this is the goal and um there's a lot of different ways to do it. The kind of obvious thing would be, well, make it cyclical. Like take some of the weights and instead of making it an acyclic graph of operations that just ends in this point, make some of those weights just point backwards.
解决那个迷宫，神经网络的权重就会持有关于那个迷宫的非常具体的信息。比如，哦，当我看到这个交叉路口时，向左转。但如果你想训练一个通用的神经网络来解决任何迷宫，并且，你知道，随着时间的推移解决它，它必须在神经网络中保持迷宫的表示，对吧？所以这是一种在线的记忆，独立于训练。所以这是目标，而且嗯，有很多不同的方法来做到这一点。显而易见的事情是，好吧，让它循环起来。比如取一些权重，而不是让它成为一个只在这个点结束的操作的无环图，让其中一些权重指向后方。
And so you execute the network. And when you execute it, some of the data is kind of left over right um and so they call us a recurrent neural network um the problem with this is they're incredibly hard to train and to learn anything meaningful um and there's a ton of reasons for this. But the biggest one is this problem called the vanishing gradient problem. And so the idea is basically if you multiply a lot of numbers less than one, you very quickly get zero, right's that's basically the gist of the vanishing gradient problem there's more complexity than that but um you know if you multiply a bunch of numbers together that are bigger than one then you quickly go to some huge number right that approaches
所以你执行网络。当你执行它时，一些数据会被遗留下来，对吧？嗯，所以他们称之为循环神经网络。这个问题在于它们极其难以训练和学习任何有意义的东西。而且这有很多原因。但最大的一个是这个问题，叫做梯度消失问题。所以这个想法基本上是，如果你乘以很多小于1的数字，你很快就会得到零，对吧？这基本上就是梯度消失问题的要点，它比这更复杂，但嗯，你知道，如果你把一堆大于1的数字乘在一起，那么你很快就会得到一个巨大的数字，对吧？接近
infinity and so that's not going to happen because you have something called regularization so that's not an issue. But the other thing where you multiply numbers smaller than one over and over again, and you get zero, that happens. And so you kind of have this sort of dilemma. It's like either everything goes to infinity or everything goes to zero. Either way, it's not really very usable um so someone came up with lstms long-term short-term memory and they basically said let's have one process that's going to infinity and let's have another process that's going to zero and then add them together and hope that like the two problems cancel each other out and uh um again it's one of these things that yes in theory you have these these long-term
无穷大，所以这不会发生，因为你有叫做正则化的东西，所以这不是问题。但当你一遍又一遍地乘以小于1的数字，你得到零，这确实会发生。所以你有点陷入了这种困境。就像要么一切都趋于无穷大，要么一切都趋于零。无论哪种方式，它都不是很有用。嗯，所以有人提出了LSTM，长短期记忆，他们基本上说，让我们有一个趋于无穷大的过程，让我们有另一个趋于零的过程，然后把它们加在一起，希望这两个问题能相互抵消。而且嗯，嗯，这又是那种理论上你确实有这些长期
you know gradients these short-term gradients and and the problems of both of them cancel each other out but in practice it just is really hard to get it to do things um throughout my career tons of people have tried to do lstms for all sorts of practical things that all these companies have worked at and it's never worked um um there's a time at facebook uh someone came up to me and said hey i have this idea um i think we'll do an lstm to predict uh um you know effects over time of people you know watching things on facebook i was like forget it i'm not interested it's not gonna work like i've just seen it fail too many times and it's it's like um you know they call this like a tar pit idea because um um you know
你知道，梯度，这些短期梯度，而且它们的问题相互抵消，但在实践中，要让它做事情真的很难。在我的职业生涯中，无数人尝试过将LSTM用于各种实际事情，所有这些公司都工作过，但它从未奏效。嗯，在Facebook时，有人来找我说，嘿，我有个想法，我想我们会做一个LSTM来预测，嗯，你知道，人们在Facebook上观看东西随时间的影响。我说，算了吧，我不感兴趣，它不会奏效。我见过它失败太多次了，而且它就像，嗯，你知道，他们称之为焦油坑想法，因为，嗯，嗯，你知道，
you don't really realize you're stuck and then and and it seems, it doesn't seem like it's a problem, maybe a quicksand idea. It's like, it doesn't seem like there's anything bad about that idea. Once you get into it, it just, it just sucks up all of your time. You don't get anything. Um, so LSTMs, you know, not much success. Um, but then something interesting kind of happened. Differentiable algebra kind of took off. So what that means is you used to, and Patrick, you might have done this like electrical engineering where they have you kind of derive all of the the updates for a neural network so they they show you like you know here's how you calculate like the the derivative of of um you know this type of
你并没有真正意识到你被困住了，然后，而且它看起来，它看起来不像是一个问题，也许是一个流沙想法。就像，它看起来那个想法没什么坏处。一旦你进入它，它就，它就吸干了你所有的时间。你什么也得不到。嗯，所以LSTM，你知道，没什么成功。嗯，但后来发生了一些有趣的事情。可微代数开始流行起来。所以这意味着你过去，帕特里克，你可能做过这个，像电气工程，他们让你推导神经网络的所有更新，所以他们向你展示，比如，你知道，这是你如何计算，比如，这种类型的导数
activation layer and you get these like exact numbers and you know exactly like you know if my answer was four and the answer should have been five then this weight in this neural network needs to go up by exactly like 1.2 times the learning rate or something and so you have these like very specific formulas and as long as you follow the formulas you'll eventually you know get to the right place um the problem is the formulas only work in certain circumstances so you couldn't for example say um you couldn't for example say like take the maximum of these three values because now like you can't differentiate the max function like there's no derivative of the hard max function
激活层，你得到这些精确的数字，而且你知道，确切地，比如，你知道，如果我的答案是4，答案应该是5，那么这个神经网络中的这个权重需要增加确切地1.2倍的学习率之类的。所以你有这些非常具体的公式，只要你遵循这些公式，你最终就会，你知道，到达正确的地方。嗯，问题是这些公式只在特定情况下有效。所以你不能，例如，说，你不能，例如，说，取这三个值的最大值，因为现在，比如，你不能对max函数求导，因为硬max函数没有导数
right and so what came what came out you know some what got popular in like around 2015 ish was this idea of numerical differentiation it's like instead of trying to come up with the derivative of all of these functions, let's numerically differentiate all of them. And so now you can actually have a gradient of the hard max function or any function. It's just a numerical gradient, a numerical approximation of a gradient. And so what that means is now you can write pretty much any code, virtually any code, and backpropagate through it. So you're not going to change that hardmax function. It is what it is. But you'll be able to differentiate through it,
对吧？所以出现了什么，你知道，在2015年左右流行起来的是数值微分的想法。就像，与其试图想出所有这些函数的导数，不如对它们进行数值微分。所以现在你实际上可以拥有硬max函数或任何函数的梯度。它只是一个数值梯度，梯度的数值近似。所以这意味着现在你可以编写几乎任何代码，几乎任何代码，并进行反向传播。所以你不会改变那个硬max函数。它就是那样。但你将能够通过它进行微分，
and things that happen before and after it that you can change will start changing. So for example, let's say I have three neural networks and then I take the max of the outputs of those three neural networks and then I have a fourth neural network. All four of those networks can be updating and learning even though they have this function in the middle that's not differentiable so all of that leads into this concept called attention layers so an attention layer is you know a set of algebra that you apply um on three things one is your query which is what are you interested in right now your keys which is how does the thing you're interested in now relate
并且在它之前和之后发生的事情，你可以改变的，将开始改变。所以例如，假设我有三个神经网络，然后我取这三个神经网络输出的最大值，然后我有第四个神经网络。所有这四个网络都可以更新和学习，即使它们中间有这个不可微的函数。所以所有这些都引出了一个概念，叫做注意力层。所以注意力层是，你知道，你应用的一组代数，针对三件事。一个是你的查询，即你现在对什么感兴趣。你的键，即你现在感兴趣的东西如何与
to the other things in your list and your values which are the other things in your list and your values, which are the other things in the list. So for example, you might say the cat jumped over the moon. Those are my values. My query is going to be, let's say, dog. And then my keys are going to be what the relationship that I think the other words have to dog. So like cat and dog probably have like a pretty close relationship, even though we joke about cats and dogs, but they have a close relationship because they're both animals, right? But you know, dog and the probably don't have a good relationship because the is just related to everything and it just washes out, right? So given your query,
你列表中的其他东西相关。以及你的值，即你列表中的其他东西。以及你的值，即列表中的其他东西。例如，你可能会说“猫跳过了月亮”。这些是我的值。我的查询将是，假设，狗。然后我的键将是，我认为其他词与狗的关系。所以像猫和狗可能有一种相当密切的关系，即使我们开玩笑说猫和狗，但它们有密切的关系，因为它们都是动物，对吧？但你知道，狗和“the”可能没有很好的关系，因为“the”只是与一切相关，它只是被冲淡了，对吧？所以给定你的查询，
your relationship of that query with each of these items and something that describes each of these items, you can then create a total amount of attention so you get um so you can say like you know dog has this much you know is capturing this much energy from that sentence um so that gets into self-attention which is just a fancy way of saying given for example a sentence take every single word in the sentence and find out how much attention the sentence offers each of those words so if you say you know the cat jumped over the moon for each of those words you know for the cat jumped you know how how much attention am i getting um from the
该查询与这些项目中的每一项的关系，以及描述这些项目中每一项的东西，你就可以创建一个总的注意力量，所以你得到，嗯，所以你可以说，比如，你知道，狗有这么多，你知道，正在从那个句子中捕获这么多能量。所以这就进入了自注意力，这只是一个花哨的说法，意思是给定一个句子，取句子中的每一个词，找出句子为每个词提供了多少注意力。所以如果你说，你知道，“猫跳过了”，你知道，我得到了多少注意力，从
other words in that sentence and for that jason so if if you're saying like cat related to dog i imagine you can look across a kind of training corpus and kind of like say how often do they appear together you know appear next to other words but for self-attention, how do you figure out that like what's holding the weight in a sentence? Yeah, so the way this works is the keys, like the weight between two words, that you're going to learn over time. So in the beginning, it's going to be just random. But then when you calculate the attention, then you take all of... And these are actually stacked on top of each other.
那个句子中的其他词。对于那个Jason，所以如果你说像猫与狗相关，我想你可以查看一种训练语料库，并说它们一起出现的频率，你知道，出现在其他词旁边。但对于自注意力，你如何弄清楚像什么在句子中保持权重？是的，它的工作方式是键，比如两个词之间的权重，你将随着时间的推移学习。所以一开始，它只是随机的。但当你计算注意力时，然后你取所有……而且这些实际上是堆叠在一起的。
So you take these stacked attention layers. So you're learning keys, you're doing the attention algebra, and then you're learning a new set of keys, and you're doing another attention algebra step. And then at the end, all of it is hopefully in service to some task. So by default, most of these models are what's called self-supervised models or forward models. So what that means is they're trying to predict the next word in the sentence. So we'll just walk through the very first training step. So you have everything token embedding that you train somewhere
所以你采用这些堆叠的注意力层。所以你在学习键，你在做注意力代数，然后你在学习一组新的键，你在做另一个注意力代数步骤。最后，所有这些都希望服务于某个任务。所以默认情况下，大多数这些模型被称为自监督模型或前向模型。所以这意味着它们试图预测句子中的下一个词。所以我们将通过第一个训练步骤。所以你有一切标记嵌入，你在某处训练
else so there's some other process that takes a word and turns it into a vector of numbers um you know that could be even all part of the same thing but usually it's broken up into two systems so so now what i have is for each word i have a vector of numbers and so i pass in let's say the cat jumped over i pass in that matrix right so it's a set of vectors of numbers and um in the beginning it's going to say well they're they're all just randomly interesting to each other. So we get a bunch of random numbers out of that, calculate the attention, do this a bunch of times. And then that's the encoding step of the transformer. So what comes out of that whole process we just talked about is a single vector.
其他地方，所以有另一个过程获取一个词并将其变成一个数字向量。嗯，你知道，那甚至可以是同一件事的一部分，但通常它被分成两个系统。所以现在我拥有的是，对于每个词，我有一个数字向量。所以我传入，假设，“猫跳过了”，我传入那个矩阵，对吧？所以它是一组数字向量。而且嗯，一开始它会说，好吧，它们对彼此来说只是随机有趣的。所以我们从中得到一堆随机数，计算注意力，做一堆次。然后这就是Transformer的编码步骤。所以我们刚才谈论的整个过程的结果是一个单一的向量。
And this is true if you're doing Lama, ChatGPT, all of these things. After all these attention layers, what comes out is a just single vector of numbers that describes the entire context of what you've seen so far um now you have to do something with that embedding and so what you usually do is you say okay i want to predict the next word so i'm going to take this embedding i'm going to create a decoder i'm going to create a function that takes the embedding as an input and outputs which word I think should go next. And so in the beginning, it's going to be totally random. Even the decoder is going to be random and it's going to output whatever, you know, foobar. It's literally going to pick a random word to output next.
而且如果你在做Llama、ChatGPT，所有这些东西，这都是真的。在所有这些注意力层之后，出来的是一个单一的数字向量，它描述了你到目前为止所见到的整个上下文。嗯，现在你必须对那个嵌入做点什么。所以你通常做的是，你说，好吧，我想预测下一个词。我要取这个嵌入，我要创建一个解码器，我要创建一个函数，它以嵌入作为输入，并输出我认为接下来应该出现的词。所以一开始，它将是完全随机的。甚至解码器也将是随机的，它将输出任何东西，你知道，foobar。它字面上将随机选择一个词作为下一个输出。
Then it's going to look at the actual word so i think i did the cat jumped over the next word is going to be the and so it's going to say oh you got it wrong it wasn't foobar it was the and so what needs to change so that next time i ask you that question you say the and so that what needs to change or that's the loss and that loss is going to be propagated all the way back and it's going to change all of the attentions among all the pairs of objects and every attention layer it's going to change the entire encoder like everything is going to change a little bit and this process then repeats a zillion times a zillion yeah and uh and so then we talked about the trying to get it is saying the comes from some training so
然后它将查看实际的词。所以我想我做了“猫跳过了”，下一个词将是“the”。所以它会说，哦，你弄错了，不是foobar，是“the”。所以需要改变什么，以便下次我问你那个问题时，你说“the”？所以那个需要改变的，或者那是损失，那个损失将被一直传播回去，它将改变所有对象对之间的所有注意力。在每个注意力层，它将改变整个编码器，一切都会改变一点点。然后这个过程重复了无数次。无数次，是的。而且嗯，所以然后我们谈到了试图让它说“the”来自某种训练，所以
you're just sticking in texts books whatever and learning hey try to guess this this next sentence yeah that's right yep so um and there's been a bunch of work on this so sometimes they try to predict sentence fragments sometimes they try to predict single words and they run it each time for for a different word um but you're right i mean people are are going through you know all of wikipedia you can download all of wikipedia there's something called common crawl which has like you know gigabytes and gigabytes of text from the internet um and these systems are going through all of this um you know taking the first n words and trying to predict the next one um and this is happening at massive massive
你只是把文本、书、任何东西放进去，学习，嘿，试着猜这个下一个句子。是的，没错。是的。所以嗯，而且在这方面已经做了很多工作。所以有时他们试图预测句子片段，有时他们试图预测单个词，并且他们每次都为不同的词运行它。但你是对的，我的意思是，人们正在经历，你知道，整个维基百科，你可以下载整个维基百科，有一种东西叫Common Crawl，它有，你知道，来自互联网的千兆字节和千兆字节的文本。而且这些系统正在经历所有这些，你知道，取前N个词并试图预测下一个。而且这正在以大规模、大规模
scale um it's just ingesting like huge volumes of text um this also works on images and video and all that as well but it's ingesting your huge volumes of text and and um and and trying to predict the the next thing um and so um yeah and so so uh it's kind of remarkable that it works at all, but there's a lot more complexity around if you dive layers deeper. Like for example, the sentence needs to make sense. And so if you're just predicting one word at a time, you might end up with things that, like the system might paint itself into a corner. And it might realize, oh, actually, I outputted this word,
规模发生。它只是摄取像海量文本。这在图像和视频以及所有这些方面也有效，但它正在摄取你的海量文本，并且，嗯，并且，并且试图预测下一个东西。所以嗯，是的，所以嗯，嗯，它能工作简直是了不起，但如果你深入挖掘层级，还有更多的复杂性。例如，句子需要有意义。所以如果你只是每次预测一个词，你可能会以这样的方式结束，比如系统可能会把自己逼入死角。它可能会意识到，哦，实际上，我输出了这个词，
but now that I've kind of gone three, four words in, I realize I made a mistake three words ago you know we even do this as humans when we're typing right and so there's uh it used to be a beam search now they're doing something else but basically there's a way where you kind of look ahead and and based on that you can kind of go back and make some changes and so it almost becomes like a search system in the decoder that's doing like a best first search yeah so the if you ever saw one of those i guess that's the hidden markov model train something would you know you feed all the harry potter books to a hidden markov model train something would, you know, you'd feed all the Harry Potter books to a hidden Markov model and ask it, you know, or on your keyboard on your phone, if you it has like
但现在我已经走了三、四个词了，我意识到我在三个词前犯了一个错误。你知道，我们人类在打字时也会这样做，对吧？所以有，嗯，过去是束搜索，现在他们正在做别的事情，但基本上有一种方法，你可以向前看，基于此，你可以回去做一些改变。所以它几乎变成了解码器中的一个搜索系统，正在做类似最佳优先搜索的事情。是的，所以如果你曾经见过其中一个，我想那是隐马尔可夫模型训练的东西，你会，你知道，你把所有的哈利波特书喂给一个隐马尔可夫模型训练的东西，你会，你知道，你把所有的哈利波特书喂给一个隐马尔可夫模型，并问它，你知道，或者在你的手机键盘上，如果它有，比如
word suggestion, if you just keep tapping the word suggestions, you get what I would call sentences, but yeah, they don't go anywhere. You're just inserting like plausible next words right after each other. And so you end up with something akin to a sentence structure but it it there's no like story or progression or statement it just you know words that come close to each other you know just happen to appear yep yep and so you know by default if you um um you know if you put like uh is it the cat or the cow jumped over the moon right yeah isn't that the same yeah i've been saying cat the whole time but if you put you know the cow jumped over the it's gonna say moon with super high accuracy because it's just seen that a bunch of times on
单词建议，如果你一直点击单词建议，你会得到我称之为句子的东西，但是的，它们哪里也去不了。你只是在每个词之后插入像合理的下一个词。所以你最终得到的东西类似于句子结构，但它，没有像故事或进展或陈述，它只是，你知道，彼此接近的词，你知道，只是碰巧出现了。是的，是的。所以你知道，默认情况下，如果你，嗯，嗯，你知道，如果你放，比如，“是猫还是牛跳过了月亮”，对吧？是的，那不是一样的吗？是的，我一直在说猫，但如果你放，你知道，“牛跳过了”，它会以极高的准确率说“月亮”，因为它只是在上面看过很多次了。
the internet right um but um so that works pretty well and so a lot of these things when you for example ask a question to chad gpt there's actually it's it's embedding your question in a prompt right because otherwise if you just took one of these naive forward models and you asked and you typed a question and said generate some text it'll probably generate more questions right like it you know it's it's it's whatever people like who wrote that kind of question would write next and so sometimes it'll generate an answer sometimes it might generate more questions um and so typically you know it might not be obvious from the user interface but you know what usually happens is you will um um you know it will put like question colon and then your question and then new paragraph
互联网，嗯，但是，嗯，所以这很有效，所以当你向 ChatGPT 提问时，很多这类事情实际上是将你的问题嵌入到提示词中，对吧？因为否则，如果你只是拿这些天真的前向模型，然后你输入一个问题并说生成一些文本，它可能会生成更多的问题，对吧？就像它会写出任何写那种问题的人接下来会写的东西，所以有时它会生成一个答案，有时它可能会生成更多的问题，嗯，所以通常你知道，从用户界面可能看不出来，但你知道通常发生的情况是，它会放入“问题：”然后是你的问题，然后是新段落。
answer colon and then the model will start generating tokens and so you didn't see the question the answer but they're there and that tells the model like like hey you know this is the broader context of what's going on um so this works pretty well uh the thing about it is um you know it's it's uh we want to be able to make improvements and so it's such a huge corpus of data that we can't it's not like normal machine learning stuff where you say, oh, I'm going to just change my data set to improve the model because the data sets like the entire internet. So like you can't, can't really do a whole lot with that. So there needs to be some way to fine tune things after the fact.
“答案：”，然后模型将开始生成标记，所以你没有看到问题和答案，但它们就在那里，这告诉模型，嘿，你知道这是正在发生的事情的更广泛的背景，所以这很有效，嗯，关于它的一点是，嗯，你知道，我们希望能够进行改进，而且这是一个如此庞大的数据语料库，以至于我们不能，这不像正常的机器学习那样，你说，哦，我要改变我的数据集来改进模型，因为数据集就像整个互联网。所以你不能，真的不能用它做太多事情。因此，事后需要有一种方法来微调事物。
And, uh, you know, once you have this forward model and so the first attempt at this which is what open ai did with their initial models was called rlhf reinforcement learning from human feedback and basically the way this works is they would have um chat gbt and this is before it was released or anything, generate four or five different answers. They would give those answers to people. The people would score the answers, and then the chat GPT model would optimize for that score and try and get the highest score possible. The problem with that is numeric scores only make sense when there's a real unit of measure. Is a score of four really twice as good as a score of two?
而且，嗯，你知道，一旦你有了这个前向模型，那么第一次尝试，也就是 OpenAI 对其初始模型所做的，被称为 RLHF，即从人类反馈中进行强化学习，基本上它的工作方式是，他们会让 ChatGPT（这是在它发布之前或任何事情之前）生成四五个不同的答案。他们会把这些答案给人们。人们会对答案进行评分，然后 ChatGPT 模型会针对该分数进行优化，并尝试获得尽可能高的分数。问题在于，只有当有真正的衡量单位时，数字分数才有意义。4 分真的比 2 分好两倍吗？
It's very hard to get people to think in such linear ways, such proportional ways. And so people are just basically the human raters are just scoring everything either a five or a one, very few two, threes, and fours. Or even if they were, it wasn't very proportional. A five wasn't five times better than a one, etc. So what's become more popular now is direct. I think it's called direct policy optimization, but basically it's pairwise ranking. So you have the system generate two answers. You give it to a person and the person decides which answer is better um and then the system is is encouraged to give the better answer and discouraged from giving the weaker answer directly um and so there's a paper that came out i think only six months ago maybe a year ago on this uh but it's as much as i love
让人以这种线性的、成比例的方式思考是非常困难的。所以人们基本上，人类评分员只是给所有东西打 5 分或 1 分，很少有 2 分、3 分和 4 分。或者即使有，也不是很成比例。5 分并不比 1 分好 5 倍，等等。所以现在更流行的是直接。我想它叫直接策略优化，但基本上它是成对排名。所以你让系统生成两个答案。你把它给一个人，那个人决定哪个答案更好，嗯，然后系统被鼓励给出更好的答案，并被直接阻止给出较弱的答案，嗯，所以有一篇论文，我想只有六个月前，也许是一年前发表的，关于这个，嗯，但是尽管我喜欢
reinforcement learning you know that was my ph, I also was pretty skeptical of this. I kind of felt like this was a poor use of reinforcement learning. And so I was not very surprised when direct policy optimization came out. And so you can imagine this is how a lot of these um things are are ironed out so a lot of ambiguities and sentences and things like that you know things that require a lot of common sense reasoning those are ironed out through through dpo so the but this works so they do the initial training you described and then they sort of like go into this fine tuning step but the answers i mean i guess they could become part of like a future training corpus but they aren't trained on the same way because if you have it generate an answer
强化学习，你知道那是我的博士学位，我也对此持怀疑态度。我有点觉得这是对强化学习的拙劣使用。所以当直接策略优化出来时，我并不感到惊讶。所以你可以想象这就是很多这些嗯事情是如何被理顺的，所以很多句子中的歧义和类似的事情，你知道需要大量常识推理的事情，这些都是通过 DPO 理顺的，所以这很有效，所以他们进行你描述的初始训练，然后他们有点像进入这个微调步骤，但答案，我的意思是，我想它们可以成为未来训练语料库的一部分，但它们不是以同样的方式训练的，因为如果你让它生成一个答案
from its current weights and then you try to tweak them that's different than showing answers from another version of you know chat gpt one or whatever and saying hey here's the responses they got or like how does that work you just sort of accumulate all of them over time yeah it's a good question let me see if i understand so so in the beginning you're you're just trying to predict the next token and there's no preference right then later on you're given a preference but for an entire answer. And so there is somewhat of a credit assignment problem there.
从它当前的权重开始，然后你尝试调整它们，这与展示来自另一个版本的 ChatGPT 1 或其他什么的答案并说“嘿，这是他们得到的回复”不同，或者这怎么运作？你只是随着时间的推移积累所有这些吗？是的，这是一个好问题，让我看看我是否理解，所以一开始你只是试图预测下一个标记，没有偏好，对吧？然后后来你被赋予了一个偏好，但针对的是整个答案。所以那里存在某种信用分配问题。
It's like, which token caused that answer to be good or bad? But again, with enough data, it works itself out. But you're right, the loss is really different. And so the way that the network is changing in that second phase is very different and so yeah you can't really go back once you've started this preference approach i mean you know you could there's nothing to stop you but it's like the two are kind of disrupting each other and so you just disrupt the first with the second and then you get what you want so yeah so if you did like 10,000 rankings i don't know how many they do at the end they don't it is not necessarily reusable like if
就像，哪个标记导致那个答案好或坏？但同样，有足够的数据，它会自行解决。但你是对的，损失确实不同。所以网络在第二阶段发生变化的方式非常不同，所以是的，一旦你开始了这种偏好方法，你就真的回不去了，我的意思是，你知道你可以，没有什么能阻止你，但这就像两者在某种程度上互相干扰，所以你只是用第二个干扰第一个，然后你得到你想要的，所以是的，所以如果你做了 1 万次排名，我不知道他们最后做了多少次，他们不，它不一定是可重用的，如果
they had a new update to the corpus or whatever they would have the weights they'd fine-tune roll them forward but they would go do another 10,000 they wouldn't just like play back oh 10,000 oh now i see what you're saying this is really interesting so um okay so you're saying you know i have chat gbt6 and uh it generates a totally different answer than the ones than either of the ones i sent to the human last time yeah so yeah this gets complicated but there is something called importance waiting and basically the gist of it is like this. When a token is generated, it's generated from a distribution. So it's not like the neural network runs and at the end it says cow.
他们对语料库进行了新的更新或其他什么，他们会有权重，他们会微调，向前推进，但他们会再做 1 万次，他们不会只是回放，哦，1 万次，哦，现在我明白你在说什么了，这真的很有趣，所以嗯，好的，所以你是说，你知道我有 ChatGPT 6，它生成的答案与我上次发给人类的任何一个答案完全不同，是的，所以是的，这变得复杂了，但有一种东西叫重要性加权，基本上它的要点是这样的。当生成一个标记时，它是从一个分布中生成的。所以不像神经网络运行，最后它说“牛”。
It actually runs and it outputs a probability over the entire space of all words that it could output. And it just happens that cow had the highest value, right? But you can normalize that output vector. And now what you get is a probability mass function over all the words so there is so for example there is a chance that chat gbt6 and chat gbt5 or chat gbt5 with two random seeds two different random seeds there is a chance that they will both generate exactly the same answer um it might be a low chance but it's there and and so there's actually, there is a chance that it will generate anything, right? Any sequence of words. And so because that chance
它实际上运行并输出一个覆盖它可以输出的所有单词空间的概率。而恰好“牛”的值最高，对吧？但你可以归一化那个输出向量。现在你得到的是所有单词上的概率质量函数，所以例如，ChatGPT 6 和 ChatGPT 5，或者带有两个随机种子的 ChatGPT 5，有两个不同的随机种子，它们都有可能生成完全相同的答案，嗯，这可能是一个很小的机会，但它存在，所以实际上，它有可能生成任何东西，对吧？任何单词序列。所以因为那个机会
is non-zero, you can do something called importance weighting where you say, okay, the new chat GPT, although it generated nothing like the two answers i sent to a human last time it still has a chance of generating those two answers and so if it's it should be it should be more likely to generate the better answer even though it it really didn't want to generate either of them oh so i think so it doesn't give the yeah like it doesn't pick the final answer it goes and looks at the distribution and says was your distribution closer to the better one or the worst one and then you can you can somewhat reuse i see oh that's that is interesting yeah exactly now the thing about importance weighting is has two problems one is um you know the easier problem is is uh those
是非零的，你可以做一种叫重要性加权的事情，你说，好的，新的 ChatGPT，虽然它生成的答案与我上次发给人类的两个答案完全不同，但它仍然有机会生成那两个答案，所以如果它是，它应该更有可能生成更好的答案，即使它真的不想生成它们中的任何一个，哦，所以我认为，所以它不给，是的，就像它不选择最终答案，它去查看分布并说你的分布是更接近更好的那个还是更差的那个，然后你可以，你可以某种程度上重用，我明白了，哦，那很有趣，是的，完全正确，现在关于重要性加权的事情有两个问题，一个是，嗯，你知道，更容易的问题是，嗯，那些
numbers are going to be small you know the chance that you do anything like with that complexity is going to be small and you're dividing small numbers against each other and so things get a little crazy there um and the other thing is oh yeah you might you might have to move a lot um or actually rather um it might be that the answer is really orthogonal to either of those two answers. It could be like almost like equidistant from both of them. Yeah, exactly. And so in that case, it doesn't matter what answer you pick then.
数字会很小，你知道你做任何具有那种复杂性的事情的机会都会很小，而你正在用小数字相互除，所以事情在那里变得有点疯狂，嗯，另一件事是，哦，是的，你可能，你可能不得不移动很多，或者实际上，嗯，可能是答案与那两个答案中的任何一个真正正交。它可能几乎就像与它们两者等距。是的，完全正确。所以在那情况下，你选择什么答案并不重要。
So it's not perfect, but you still get a lot of value out of it. It's not like that old work was wasted. Oh, that's cool yeah i mean because i guess like when you're moving up versions you could ask it a question and in one case it generates two different diatribes about cows and moons but then in the next one it generates a picture of a cow jumping over a moon and actually that is better but then now you're stuck with this problem of like oh i have a picture versus two sentences and so yeah i hear yeah yeah makes sense but yeah the data mode is real you know i mean all this data and all that human effort that's gone into labeling
所以它并不完美，但你仍然从中获得了很多价值。这不像旧的工作被浪费了。哦，那很酷，是的，我的意思是，因为我想当你升级版本时，你可以问它一个问题，在一种情况下，它生成了关于牛和月亮的两个不同的抨击，但在下一个版本中，它生成了一张牛跳过月亮的图片，实际上那更好，但现在你陷入了这个问题，就像，哦，我有一张图片对比两个句子，所以是的，我听到了，是的，是的，有道理，但是的，数据模式是真实的，你知道，我的意思是所有这些数据以及投入到标记中的所有人类努力
and ranking all of that data is just permanently valuable so um so yeah it's a huge boon for for a lot of these companies have started early that was that was uh so the large language model uh and then we talked about all this so the large there just comes from the fact that the parameter count has gotten so numerous and it happens to be that these large language models today have a very similar architecture that you're describing and not so much that there's like you couldn't do it a different way right so no of a different better way yeah exactly so so the the recurrent neural network you couldn't make it large because the gradients would vanish the lstm you couldn't make it large because it was an unstable equilibrium
并且对所有这些数据进行排名是永久有价值的，所以嗯，所以是的，这对很多早期开始的公司来说是一个巨大的福音，那是，那是，嗯，大型语言模型，然后我们谈论了所有这些，所以“大型”只是来自参数数量变得如此众多这一事实，而且碰巧今天这些大型语言模型具有你描述的非常相似的架构，而不是说你不能用不同的方式做到这一点，对吧？所以没有一种不同的更好的方式，是的，完全正确，所以所以循环神经网络，你不能把它做大，因为梯度会消失，LSTM 你不能把它做大，因为它是一个不稳定的平衡
and so the current the gradients would either vanish again or explode and so so you couldn't do it but with the uh you know the attention layers in the beginning a lot of people myself included were a little skeptical of the attention approach because um it felt like a strange compromise between you know convolution where you have like a relatively small mask but because the mask is small it can kind of like rove roving eye you know through an image kind of compromise between that and an lstm which in theory has like an infinite horizon. Like you could, in theory, you could feed, you know, a near infinite amount of, not literally infinite, but you could feed an extremely large amount of data to LSTM.
因此，当前的梯度要么再次消失，要么爆炸，所以你做不到，但有了嗯，你知道，开始时的注意力层，很多人，包括我自己，对注意力方法有点怀疑，因为嗯，它感觉像是你所知道的卷积之间的一种奇怪的妥协，你有像一个相对较小的掩码，但因为掩码很小，它可以像在图像中游走一样，你知道，在那种和 LSTM 之间的一种妥协，LSTM 在理论上具有无限的视野。就像你可以，理论上，你可以输入，你知道，近乎无限量的，不是字面上的无限，但你可以输入极大量的数据到 LSTM。
It could remember all of it. There's no limit. So attention was strange in that, you know, it had a lot of the features of long-term, short-term, but it didn't have the benefits um but you know the fact that it was a stable training that was really incredibly useful it's one of these things that's hard to know because in theory everything is stable right it's hard to know in practice like what will this do if you have seven billion
它可以记住所有这些。没有限制。所以注意力很奇怪，因为，你知道，它有很多长期、短期的特征，但它没有好处，嗯，但你知道，它是稳定训练的事实，这真的非常有用，这是很难知道的事情之一，因为在理论上一切都是稳定的，对吧？在实践中很难知道，如果你有 70 亿，这会做什么
worth of this right and it held up really well at that scale yeah that's really interesting so it's like when you grow really big it was hard to predict what would happen but that yeah it has the attributes that sort of end up working at that scale and the compromise. But I guess like to the same thing, it doesn't mean it's none of this means that it is the sort of like optimal or correct answer. It's just the best we know today. So if we found a new LST, I mean,
价值的这个，对吧？它在那个规模上保持得非常好，是的，这真的很有趣，所以就像当你长得非常大时，很难预测会发生什么，但那，是的，它具有最终在那个规模上起作用的属性，以及妥协。但我猜就像同样的事情，这并不意味着它是某种最优或正确的答案。这只是我们今天所知的最好的。所以如果我们发现了一个新的 LST，我的意思是，
maybe not, but like LST, I'm like, or you found a new way of, you know, solving the problems or adding another thing. It could do better, but we just don't know that today.
也许不是，但像 LST，我像，或者你发现了一种新的，你知道，解决问题或添加另一件事的方法。它可能会做得更好，但我们今天只是不知道。
So someone would have to figure it out. Yep. Yep. Um, now here's where it gets really tricky is, um, you know, all of this is, um, very direct. Like, you know, you have this direct policy optimization, you know, the RLHF was technically reinforcement learning but um it was it was you know a very direct approach and so a lot of these systems you know they can't actually do things like they can't they can't get rewarded or punished really um
所以有人必须弄清楚它。是的。是的。嗯，现在这里变得非常棘手的是，嗯，你知道，所有这些都是，嗯，非常直接的。就像，你知道，你有这个直接策略优化，你知道，RLHF 在技术上是强化学习，但嗯，它，它，你知道，一种非常直接的方法，所以很多这些系统，你知道，它们实际上不能做事情，就像它们不能，它们不能真正得到奖励或惩罚，嗯
and if they do it's this really sort of brute way where you know you could tell chat gpt like go invest in stocks like oh you're bankrupt that was bad you know it's like but it can't it can't it can't really reason in a way like it can't sort of build a world model that it can then use to reason and to make decisions. So I think the future of this is this really interesting work coming out of Facebook called JEPA, which is I think Joint Embedding Policy Architecture. But it's basically a way to combine a lot of these embedding approaches, whether it's a large language model or a large image model, or maybe it's a large, you know, actuator motor response module or something doesn't necessarily have to be language, but a way to sort of combine those with decision making. And I think that's really going to be super exciting but it's going to take a while for that research to mature yeah so i guess like to your point we were talking about
如果它们这样做，这是一种非常粗暴的方式，你知道你可以告诉 ChatGPT 像去投资股票，哦，你破产了，那很糟糕，你知道，就像，但它不能，它不能，它不能真正以那种方式推理，就像它不能某种程度上建立一个世界模型，然后它可以用它来推理和做出决定。所以我认为这的未来是来自 Facebook 的这项非常有趣的工作，叫 JEPA，我认为是联合嵌入策略架构。但它基本上是一种结合很多这些嵌入方法的方式，无论是大型语言模型还是大型图像模型，或者也许它是一个大型，你知道，执行器电机响应模块或其他什么，不一定非要是语言，但一种将它们与决策结合起来的方式。我认为这真的会超级令人兴奋，但这项研究成熟需要一段时间，是的，所以我猜就像你的观点，我们刚才谈论的
earlier uh picking a racing line and driving your car towards it you could tell chat gbt or one of these large language models how you want and it maybe could generate your code or something but it can't actually go play the game itself like it doesn't it doesn't have the hooks it doesn't have the inputs to go do it there's no module and this the architecture isn't really set up to you know be a mario kart ai agent right and then you know people joke about telling chat gbt like your answer is terrible and then it generates another one and yeah that's funny but but really it's not it's not really um you're trying to optimize for some objective like it will pivot um but but even that pivot is is kind of artificial it's not really directionally heading towards some place of greater value and so you
早些时候，选择一条赛车路线并驾驶你的车朝它开去，你可以告诉 ChatGPT 或这些大型语言模型之一你想要什么，它也许可以生成你的代码或其他什么，但它不能真正自己去玩游戏，就像它没有，它没有钩子，它没有输入去执行它，没有模块，而且这个架构并没有真正设置为，你知道，成为一个马里奥赛车 AI 代理，对吧？然后你知道，人们开玩笑说告诉 ChatGPT 像你的答案很糟糕，然后它生成另一个，是的，那很有趣，但但实际上它不是，它不是真的，嗯，你试图为某个目标进行优化，就像它会转向，但但即使那个转向也是某种人工的，它并没有真正朝着某个更有价值的地方前进，所以你
know yeah you can't plug chat gbt straight into mario kart and like over time get something that get it to produce python code that gives you a higher and higher score over time like there's not an easy way to do that yet yeah yeah so the i always find that funny i guess like that i don't know it's anthropomorphizing it's not the right way but you're right people like fuss at chat gpt like i'm gonna i'm gonna kill you if you you know i'm gonna unplug you if you do one more thing but it's all just adding to the context it's not like you said it's not actually evolving forward so you you could just written all of that out and claimed what it told you like is what it told you even though it didn't and just put it all in the prompt and it would do the same thing
知道，是的，你不能把 ChatGPT 直接插入马里奥赛车，然后随着时间的推移得到一些东西，让它产生 Python 代码，随着时间的推移给你越来越高的分数，就像还没有一种简单的方法可以做到这一点，是的，是的，所以我总是觉得那很有趣，我猜就像，我不知道，这是拟人化，这不是正确的方法，但你是对的，人们喜欢对 ChatGPT 大惊小怪，像“我要，我要杀了你，如果你，你知道，如果你再做一件事，我就拔掉你的插头”，但这只是增加了背景，不像你说的，它并没有真正向前进化，所以你本来可以写下所有这些，并声称它告诉你的就是它告诉你的，即使它没有，只是把它全部放在提示词中，它也会做同样的事情
right in other words like if someone comes back to you and says jason you're bad because you did this thing and you didn't do that thing you're going to be like what no like you're just going to ignore it but with chat gbt if it gives you an output if you were to start a new session and copy that what it told you and what your response was into the very beginning, it's the same. Like it's not actually like remembering and evolving in that way. It's just building this ongoing context that kind of feels similar. Right. And, and all of this, you know, even what's coming in the future is not going to kill coding. Like we should spend probably the last five minutes of the show talking about this. But if you are a follower of this show, you know, maybe you are working professional or not yet,
对吧，换句话说，如果有人回来对你说，杰森，你很糟糕，因为你做了这件事，而你没有做那件事，你会说，什么，不，就像你只是会忽略它，但对于 ChatGPT，如果它给你一个输出，如果你要开始一个新的会话，并把它告诉你的内容和你的回复复制到最开始，是一样的。就像它并没有真正像那样记忆和进化。它只是在构建这种持续的背景，感觉有点相似。对。而且，所有这些，你知道，即使是未来会发生的事情，也不会扼杀编程。我们应该花节目的最后五分钟谈谈这个。但如果你是这个节目的追随者，你知道，也许你是职场人士，或者还不是，
you're in college and you're thinking, oh, if I major in computer science, there won't be a job for me because Jack GVT will have my job. That is not going to happen. You know, I think coding is just a way of solving problems at the end of the day. And so the medium might change, but the need to solve hard problems is not going away anytime
你在上大学，你在想，哦，如果我主修计算机科学，我就不会有工作了，因为 ChatGPT 会抢走我的工作。那不会发生。你知道，我认为编程归根结底只是一种解决问题的方法。所以媒介可能会改变，但解决难题的需求不会很快消失。
soon. And if anything, ChatGPT will actually automate everyone else's job. People who are solving easier problems, those are the people who really should be worried. If you're in here listening to the show, show going to college or even on your own learning to be a programmer you're doing it because you want to solve hard problems and that's doing hard things really mentally difficult things is give me one of the last things to get automated yeah i i mean i think they've always talked about it for a long time and accuracy hasn't been there but i the one i always think about is like i don't just use it so much like x-ray tech it's like you go in and you know you have a broken arm and you get your x-ray and the
而且如果有的话，ChatGPT 实际上会自动化其他所有人的工作。那些正在解决更容易问题的人，那些才是真正应该担心的人。如果你在这里听这个节目，去上大学，或者甚至自己学习成为一名程序员，你这样做是因为你想解决难题，而这，做困难的事情，真正精神上困难的事情，是我最后被自动化的事情之一，是的，我的意思是，我认为他们已经谈论了很长时间，准确性一直没有达到，但我总是想到的是，像，我不只是用它那么多，像 X 光技术，就像你进去，你知道，你手臂骨折了，你拍了 X 光片，然后
the job of the person who i don't know what the right word reads the x-ray like looks at the x-ray is supposed to look at the notes from the doctor about what they think was wrong look at the x-ray and check for problems and then like write a. But if you gave it to 100 doctors, they won't all say the same thing. But there is a correct reading of the chart. And hopefully, most of them would give the same answer. This one feels like very difficult before you would just given it to like, you know, something that would use like Jason was mentioning a convolutional neural network or something try to highlight where the fracture is. but now you're getting to the point where you could give the context of the doctor's notes and hey i was in an accident and my arm is hurting and you know here's my and so
那个人的工作，我不知道正确的词是什么，读取 X 光片，就像看 X 光片，应该看医生关于他们认为出了什么问题的笔记，看 X 光片并检查问题，然后写一个。但如果你把它给 100 个医生，他们不会都说同样的话。但图表有一个正确的解读。希望他们大多数人会给出同样的答案。这一个感觉非常困难，在你只是把它给像，你知道，某种会使用像杰森提到的卷积神经网络或其他什么东西，尝试突出骨折在哪里之前。但现在你到了可以提供医生笔记背景的地步，嘿，我出了事故，我的手臂很痛，你知道，这是我的，所以
it would you know kind of understand what it's attempting to do and you're right those things are problem solving but not really in the same way that like like you said, hey, I want to build a game where you're a go-kart racing turtle and throw shells at each other. And that kind of problem solving is a fundamentally different approach. Right, right. And also, you know, when you're building anything, this is true of anything you're building, software or anything. There's really two things that you're constantly adapting to. One is product market fit. Are people enjoying my game? Who is enjoying the game?
它会，你知道，某种程度上理解它试图做什么，你是对的，那些事情是解决问题，但并不是真正像，就像你说的，嘿，我想做一个游戏，你是一只卡丁车赛车乌龟，互相扔龟壳。那种解决问题的方法是一种根本不同的方法。对，对。而且，你知道，当你构建任何东西时，这适用于你构建的任何东西，软件或任何东西。你不断适应的确实有两件事。一个是产品市场契合度。人们喜欢我的游戏吗？谁在享受这个游戏？
And then the second one is quality of life. So maybe my game is actually fun, but there's too many buttons in the menu and people like are like not even getting past the main menu. Right. And so you have to constantly adapt to all of these changes and you have to decide like what parts to be flexible, what parts of the code should be inflexible and written quickly. And these are all things that, you know, trade-offs that ChatGPT is not going to make very effectively or any AI is not going to make very effectively. So, you know, and who's to say what's going to happen way out in the distant future. But I would say, you know, if you're listening to this show, if you're interested in this topic, your job is extremely safe. I think that you can if if you
然后第二个是生活质量。所以也许我的游戏实际上很有趣，但菜单里的按钮太多了，人们就像甚至没有通过主菜单。对。所以你必须不断适应所有这些变化，你必须决定，像哪些部分要灵活，哪些部分的代码应该不灵活并快速编写。这些都是，你知道，ChatGPT 不会非常有效地做出的权衡，或者任何 AI 都不会非常有效地做出。所以，你知道，谁能说遥远的未来会发生什么。但我会说，你知道，如果你在听这个节目，如果你对这个话题感兴趣，你的工作是非常安全的。我认为你可以，如果，如果
said oh i'm going to pivot to accounting well that's that's probably uh not unwise no i mean i brought their laws and accountants so it's not an insult to accountants but i'm just saying you know you are in a very safe profession this idea that coding is dead or will be automated is absurd and uh don't worry about it and yeah in like normal term i think there's a caveat there like who knows what happens in a thousand years but yeah exactly i but again i think you know your job will be one of the last ones to go so by then i saw this crazy stat that like 99 of job titles didn't exist 100 years ago something like that oh interesting yeah yeah i mean i think like uh taking taking as an example like someone who's an actor or something which i know that there there's a bunch of politics around that and fighting whatever but
你说，哦，我要转向会计，嗯，那，那可能，嗯，并不不明智，不，我的意思是，我带来了他们的法律和会计师，所以这不是对会计师的侮辱，但我只是说，你知道，你处于一个非常安全的职业中。这种编程已死或将被自动化的想法是荒谬的，嗯，不要担心它，是的，在正常情况下，我认为有一个警告，像谁知道一千年后会发生什么，但是的，完全正确，我，但我再次认为，你知道，你的工作将是最后消失的工作之一，所以到那时，我看到了这个疯狂的统计数据，像 99% 的职位名称在 100 年前不存在，类似那样，哦，有趣，是的，是的，我的意思是，我想像，嗯，以像演员或其他什么为例，我知道那里，那里有一堆关于那个的政治，和战斗什么的，但
taking an actor and their voice and their body image and like the way they like this is very easy easy to join on and then like get them to do new things and become an ai agent of some sort and you know probably like they call those people quote unquote talent but like their talent is something very very specific uh and mostly a function of how they look and how they sound and so um you know even the things that they do on camera all scripted right the writers and the producers and and all of that stuff and so yeah i i think you're right without saying when or if i mean saying one of the last to go is a reassuring fact yeah i mean you would be late enough that you you would see the writing on the wall and you would pivot to one of the 99
拿一个演员和他们的声音和他们的身体形象，以及他们喜欢的方式，这很容易加入，然后让他们做新的事情，成为某种 AI 代理，你知道，可能像他们称那些人为“所谓的人才”，但像他们的人才是一些非常非常具体的东西，主要是他们看起来如何以及他们听起来如何的函数，所以嗯，你知道，即使他们在镜头前做的事情都是写好的，对吧？编剧和制片人，以及所有那些东西，所以是的，我想你是对的，不用说什么时候或是否，我的意思是说最后消失的工作之一是一个令人放心的事实，是的，我的意思是你会足够晚，你会看到墙上的字，你会转向未来一百年出现的 99
percent of jobs that are coming out in the next hundred years i've seen i've seen the matrix your job is to become a heater eat food walk around in the matrix and provide warmth for the robots the robot army so good all right folks i think we'll put a wrap on that if you have any questions about lms join our discord um i do have discord's one of the few apps i actually have notifications turned on so when people post in discord i do see it right away um join our discord uh you know support us on patreon we really love and thank all of our supporters um you know we're putting all that money back in this show trying to get more more people, kids, adults into programming. And we will catch everybody next show.
百分之的工作，我见过，我见过黑客帝国，你的工作是成为一个加热器，吃食物，在黑客帝国里走来走去，为机器人，机器人军队提供温暖，所以很好，好的，伙计们，我想我们会结束这个，如果你对 LM 有任何问题，加入我们的 Discord，嗯，我确实有 Discord，是我实际上开启了通知的少数几个应用程序之一，所以当人们在 Discord 上发帖时，我确实会马上看到它，嗯，加入我们的 Discord，嗯，你知道，在 Patreon 上支持我们，我们真的爱并感谢我们所有的支持者，嗯，你知道，我们把所有的钱都投入到这个节目中，试图让更多更多的人，孩子，成年人进入编程。我们会在下个节目见到大家。
Thanks, everyone. Music by Eric Varndollar. music by eric barn dollar programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide an attribution uh to uh patrick and i and uh share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢大家。音乐由 Eric Varndollar 提供。音乐由 Eric Varndollar 提供。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发，你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，以重新混合、改编作品，但你必须提供署名，嗯，给 Patrick 和我，并以相同方式共享。此剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。